Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
The first man to smoke marijuana never
really smoked it and held.
It was a Chinese man.
He was a very great man and whenever he
lit the plant,
it wasn't to get high,
but he would start to get high and every
time he got high,
a blue bird would come to him and tell
him to conquer his neighboring
neighborhoods and he listened to those
to the bird and that's exactly what he
did and he became a great emperor in
China at that point in the story.
Pablo Escobar because his doctor and he
goes,
have you ever been to Disney land?
And the doctor goes,
no,
Pablo,
I have this very clean,
very organized.
Well that's it,
but it's the truth.
First gather Chinese dude that burnt the
plant because he liked the smell of the
plant and gave him a soothing.
But after days of doing it,
it packed up in his body and he started
to loosen that and he saw a blue bird.
Blue Bird came to him and told him that
he had to conquer the neighborhoods
within a region or crazy bird.
He got high and a bird started talking
to them.
What are you gonna do you know?
Uh,
I don't know if this is true,
but this is one of the things that are
the part of fishing Nana was always used
to say is that,
you know,
when a priest walks down the aisle and
they have that thing that they swing and
there's burning incense inside of it.
They used to be,
we'd.
That's what they used to do was to be in
what dimension?
I don't know.
At one point,
I believe it was,
we got it became that shit that Batman
shot at the Green Hornet like pedophile
smoke.
You,
you wake up,
your shirts bombed backwards.
This shit.
Your pants are missing.
Well,
what did,
what is it now?
What kind of instances?
It's smoke.
I,
I go in there,
the church,
every once in a while now you have to go
for the full effect.
One like the five in the afternoon on
Saturday and the early morning Sunday
they don't break out the incense that
don't start breaking out the fucking
Melaleuca fucking some kid and the guy
comes out and when the guy comes out
their own water,
Jesus and then the other guy.
It's so weird how somebody made a great
point on twitter the other day.
They said,
you me,
Mitch Hedberg,
if there's five of us to deliver
newspapers is $5.
The delivered newspapers.
You Hedberg did it?
Yeah.
You delivered them in a call the other
places I was an asshole that took a
route but not the route in my
neighborhood.
The route in the neighborhood over,
so I had to beat the kids there before
they get there and steal the papers.
I would deliver them right to the doors
and all.
You did too and then you collected.
I collected from only a handful of
people.
Most
people are on like a monthly
subscription plan.
They had.
They were switching over,
but the people that you'd have to
collect from Yeley this envelope,
like a tan envelope and you had to mark
off like,
you know when they owe things that I
barely remember it because it was only a
couple of the clients and after awhile I
kind of got away from doing them.
I said,
I don't want to do these people that
have because it's too hard to collect.
It's annoying.
Like I don't want to.
I don't want to have to go to.
That was I didn't like it must have
been.
That was just when I first got a
Catholic school and my mom gave me an
option that I had to go up there and
work in the afternoon.
I got to figure something out.
I just don't want to go up there anymore
and my friend said I'm giving up my
newspaper route,
but he didn't give up the one that my
navel.
He gave up the one and the next city
over the next town over that city.
I could still walk day so I'd have to
leave school run over there because of
not the dude who steal my papers and
sell them as their own,
the fucking street corners,
so I'd have to get them,
put the circulars in,
put them in a thing and then throw them
on people's balcony and then on Fridays
and Saturdays I have to go back with a
ring after dinner and collect.
How you doing Mr Rogan.
I'm here to pick up seventy five cents
and they give you like a dollar 50.
That was your tip and you got like
twenty two cents a week for the of the
paper.
Did you collect from everybody?
I collected from everybody.
I was this.
What years were these?
This has to be 73.
Seventy four.
Seventy five.
Yeah.
So I guess when I started doing it is
when I started driving,
which had been like 83.
I probably started 83.
I probably started when I was 17.
No,
that was 85.
80 five probably.
Then that's when I probably started
doing it.
Or you're too old to be collected.
I wouldn't be either.
Well it wasn't even that,
it was just annoying,
like what you wanted to do was go to the
depot,
pick up the papers,
chuck them into the People's driveways
and that's it.
And then there was a few people that
wanted it inside the door so you'd have
to get out of your car,
open up their screen door,
put it in there and then leave.
And the idea was that those people,
everybody would say those people tip you
better.
Those two,
Delta p Bennett Miller.
Okay.
And so we would only have like a few of
those and I think after the first couple
of years they stopped doing those kinds
of collections or I definitely stopped
doing them.
But it was an awesome job when you were
like a young comic or you know,
even before it was a comical and I was
fighting,
it was just a.
I didn't have to do anything where
someone was telling me what to do.
I could get my car,
I could listen to whatever I wanted to.
I listened to Charles Laquidara,
he had a,
the morning the big mattress on,
I think it was bcn.
I'm pretty sure it's wbcn in Boston,
which is awesome radio show.
I listened to that.
Chuck newspapers out windows.
I do that for like three hours every
day,
you know?
It was the best ever because
then I would make enough money where I
could pay my bills,
but I still had all the time in the
world.
You stand up
all the time,
the world train all the time in the
world do anything,
but it definitely fucked me up because
you're not supposed to be getting up
that early every day.
Like that can't be good for you.
You know,
if you listen to people that know things
about sleep,
like getting up at 4:30
in the morning or five in the morning
every day and not being responsible.
That was the beginning.
To me.
That was the beginning of the new Joe
Rogan podcast.
That was the first podcast I listened to
that I agreed with a lot.
What else?
I had a couple of mitigating factors
because I believe that everybody's body
is a lot different.
I know I could rock and roll.
I could throw down on seventh street,
but it's got to be seven straight.
No,
nothing.
No.
Get up the two times because once you're
50 it could be up and down.
See,
once you turn 50,
48,
everything changed his papa.
So if you had night chicken come to it
was.
It has to come up throughout the night
and you will be up all fucking night on
the hour.
Every hour.
There's no rem sleep.
So you have to come control once you get
old,
you have to control your thyroid dog.
I've been a specialist on asleep since
day one.
That was one of the most interesting
podcasts you had.
I bought the book and everything and he
made some great points in there.
I didn't.
I wasn't raised under that.
Joe Rogan.
My mom didn't raise me once we came from
Cuba,
my dad died.
There was no nap.
I went with.
She went right.
So Mike Day Consisted of eight to three
in the morning.
She had a manager's room in the back of
the bar with a cop.
If I got tired at one,
go back there and take a nap,
but I gotta stay here till three Momma
got to work.
Wow.
So my sleep was always her and then when
I was five or six in school that I went
to normal sleep,
I went to Catholic grammar school,
normal sleep,
everything was normal,
but my mom had a bad thing that she did.
My mom had an issue that a lot of
parents don't do when they work nights.
It was.
She did it from the heart because I have
a friend who does it.
Wake you up at three in the morning,
Joe Rogan,
Joe Rogan.
Get up black ink and Pasta,
which really from them burritos.
And I brought you a newspaper.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Can you imagine if I woke you up and it
to when you're 26 years old joe at 3:30
in the morning and you know I'm doing it
from my heart and seven out of 10 times
you're going to get up and eat the
school.
Julie or the or the Marinara Sandwich I
brought you from Leo is because they
worked in the city,
so if you remember,
if you bartending in New York City on
the way home,
he stopped.
No,
you stopped and get two slices of
fucking the best pizza there isn't
Manhattan.
So my mom would wake me up every night
at 3:30
in the morning with the Cuban sandwich
that killed me over the years.
That would make me get up every night at
three.
They're still nights that I'll be
sleeping.
I get a good night's sleep,
but I'll look at the clock and it's 3:00
AM on the fucking died because it's in
my.
But like last night I slept good.
I fucked up.
My sleep was bad after I read the book
for a while.
That's how deep it got into my head.
So when I went back to weightwatchers I
realized I couldn't eat anymore fucking
edibles because they wouldn't.
They would make me hungry at night.
I would fucking go off the charts with
points.
So I stopped eating edibles and Joe
Rogan.
My sleep pattern changed bad,
like my body did not know how to go to
fall asleep by itself.
I went through a month or two while I
was asleep.
Jesus doing with a bunch of shit and
then three more hours.
Yeah.
Did you try anything?
Did you try like Melatonin or anything
like that?
I did cocaine for 30 years and Melatonin
the 23rd stick it all suck.
My Dick Gaba,
Gaba,
google,
Google.
I drink them all together.
The vine.
Leave me alone.
Please leave me the fuck alone.
Fuck this.
Awesome.
I got something.
That's Gaba,
Gaba the tea and the trip depending put
together and they still don't find.
I buy it on Amazon.
I'm bad.
So what I learned to do was rotate it.
So now I'm back on the animals.
I found that about an expired bag of
Chiba chews,
like the Dave Chappelle to when I went
out with Dave and I found the bag with
about 24.
Oh my God.
I slice them in half.
You take one of those where you wake up
at six in the morning.
[inaudible] Brown expired.
You understand me?
What happened to me?
IED expired edibles.
Same thing when you eating expired
Vikatin.
Listen to this.
Listen to this shit.
Ain't fucking around though.
This works.
The jaw.
This is.
You got to fight Joe Schilling.
He to have these copies back on Monday.
Ain't ain't nobody knocking you out
after he eat one of these times.
Things don't put you in another
dimension.
My God,
I've been in a fucking another dimension
since last week and I don't give a fuck.
I have not left the house in a week.
Do you understand me?
I ate two of them on Saturday.
I know you up at night or how beautiful
though.
Beautiful.
Mangement.
Tremendous.
The nicest people.
I took a bunch of really smart people
that it,
you know,
fuck him.
Fuck Portland.
Fuck New York.
Fuck Chicago.
Take to get mad with blowing up boise.
They want to keep it low key.
They want to keep them low.
Kids fucking all of those areas.
You can ski up there.
Ain't got everything up there.
Nobody knows.
Yeah.
They got couple people that hate black
people,
but they keep on the side of the state.
Mark Furman's up there,
fucking Oj sister in law.
You know what I'm saying?
It's all right.
It turned right.
No,
no,
no.
It's beautiful.
Then you went to sign.
My friend who I kidnap showed up your
show.
He said he had a great time.
I go,
why don't you say a little Brogan?
You could have done a podcast right
there.
You said he was embarrassed,
but Saturday night I paid the fucking
edible Joe Rogan.
I ate two of these expired ones.
I eat one that I said,
let me take a chance.
It's Saturday night and a nother one and
I noticed your movie was coming up and
it is fucking what a phenomenal movie.
Midnight Express.
When they catch the kid coming back from
Turkey with Hash on his body,
Joe Rogan.
That is one of the most hardest movies
you ever fucking watch in the Goddamn
the first 30 minutes of that like I
thought I was going to die.
Like when they let him go through and
they played him and as soon as he hit
the fucking plane,
they turned them around,
ripped his shirt,
and they dropped in their hands and
knees and they gave him the seven years
and they started raping them.
Jesus.
But I watched up to the part where
fucking he became friends with this
dude.
They had a cat and the dude name was
likey likey like he was the guy's name
and Leckie killed the cat and they let
this American.
Now you don't have point where even
Michael Douglas and was that movie.
He's on the four or five and he just
snaps fighting back.
Michael.
Then they tried to rob them.
The three Mexicans try to rob him from
the suitcase.
What was that?
Sorry?
What was falling down?
Falling.
He had like his day like that was it.
That was the last day to fucking live.
This
finds that they killed that poor
Americans cat and he throws a fucking
beat on this left dude.
Joe Rogan isn't one of the most
disturbing beatings.
There's too disturbing beatings or film
history.
That's number two because he closes it
out because the guy was a rat,
so after he throws a beat man,
look.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Right there.
He spitting up and guy's tongue in the
air and they showed it on.
I gotta give a shout out.
The Turner classic movies.
You motherfuckers been growing heat the
last six days they had on something else
last night that the gambler on the other
night that followed this.
This is the 40th anniversary,
Joe Rogan.
He throws a beat man.
Them opens his mouth.
I'm thinking the guy's being a nice guy.
He's going to give him mouth to mouth
and saved the guy's life fucked low.
You see him going and he just pulls up
like this,
Joe.
They slow it up.
Only I'll call fucking real director
that on the waterfront last night.
Jesus ain't fucking around.
And they once I was watching like what
is the commercials?
And they said,
fuck.
One time I had my mother's will play
this hand.
Now they're going to show the tongue.
Joe Rogan.
He takes it out.
Did you could see the rage from the
fucking eight years in a Turkish jail
getting fucked in the ass?
Eat that Hummus,
drinking that fuck them watered down tea
from Korea and he just spits his fucking
look at this.
Beaten the best beat in of all time.
There's only one better beaten.
Our board a Mexican when he beat up a
pilot.
This is Leptin.
Jesus.
Dude,
I forgot about this move.
This is a classic.
This is a classic seventies movie.
This is crazy,
dude.
Look at him.
He's just.
This is eight years of getting beat up
every day.
I'm not.
I'm gonna fucking kill you.
You fucking fuck dude.
This is an intense scene.
What year is this moving?
Seventy eight.
I was a kid.
I still remember going to see this in
the movies.
I'm leaving.
They're like dog.
I ain't ever gone to Turkey.
Jesus Christ.
The scene for the people that are just
listening.
Um,
he's,
he's tearing apart this bathroom to get
it.
This guy,
I don't remember who the guy is.
He is the guy that sells more than down
hash and he rats you out and he's just a
creepy fucking dude,
and then to finally push them over to
tap,
he hangs his hat.
He wakes up to his cat being hung and
right here people.
This is the fucking strength of the
seventies.
Balls to the wall.
Oh,
smashes.
Yeah.
No,
this is real deal.
Real right here,
Huh?
Oh Shit.
Are you fucking nuts?
Good morning.
Here's the fourth of July.
You're fucking with an American
motherfuckers.
Even in Turkey,
we lose our fucking minds.
That guy must've been half Armenian when
he bit his tongue out.
There you go.
Dude.
This was.
This guy.
Ended up dying of AIDS in real life.
This is a strong,
strong.
Next time you had guy was a real life
guy in this guy.
The actor.
Who was he?
What was his name?
I forget what his name.
Brett.
Brad Davis.
Jesus.
Then the second best beating is our man
Anthony Quinn.
At the end when he was 80,
he beat the shit out of the good looking
dude for fucking his girl friend,
Mariel stope.
Madeline stowe and a movie called
revenge that.
Oh yeah,
I remember revenge.
Kevin Cost Kevin Costner and then he
slices a face and he fucking put your in
a whorehouse right?
Fucked in the ass every hour on the
hour.
Fucking this is it.
It's a fourth of July.
Get his shit
together.
You know what I'm saying?
If Alex Jones is correct,
we'll go on and have a civil war today.
So what the fuck you talked to Alex,
you've got to calm them down.
Alex.
you gotta calm down talking about a
civil war.
He had me doing an extra achievement.
Judy the other night I was polishing the
fuck and the musket.
Alex thinks I'm defending the new world
order because I didn't think that George
Soros was a Nazi.
It's also painful.
What's up Joe?
Rob?
Nothing.
What's happening brother?
Everything's great,
man.
I mean,
I feel good.
Alex Jones.
I love you buddy for real.
But you say some silly shit.
That's where this all comes from.
It doesn't mean I don't love you.
You're a great guy,
but there's some shit that's just silly.
It's wasted time.
You know?
That's one of those things,
it's just a waste of time.
Does that make sense?
I'm with you.
I think there's real conspiracies,
you know,
but I think there's some that,
people just get caught up and looking
for conspiracies and everything and
after a while it's exhausting.
Let's get the ball off the table.
I love the guy with the podcasts with
already last week,
yesterday,
18 attorney's son.
Alex Jones going to hear that.
So I'm just like,
I'll finish.
Okay.
I'm so sorry.
No,
it's okay.
It's just,
I love the guy.
I really do.
I just don't support a lot of the shit
that he said.
Like the sandy hook stuff.
I don't know if he's since disavowed
that.
I don't know if he changed his opinion
on it.
I don't know what it is,
but at a certain point in time you're
like,
Jesus,
man,
are you,
are you sure?
Like,
you got to be really sure before you say
something crazy like that.
Right,
don't you?
I mean,
don't you think?
Look,
I think he's a great guy and as a person
I'm not attacking it.
I just,
uh,
when he goes crazy and gets mad at me,
I love,
I want to hug them.
I love Lee told me this story about
trucks pulling up in front of your house
and they could see through your walls.
They probably can do that.
They do that in different neighborhoods.
You know,
I like to do something like that,
but then have to five of those and this
was my experience.
He'll tell you something that you got to
sit there and go,
what the fuck am I doing sitting here?
But that's cool.
That's Alex and we accept them for what
the fuck is.
I just thought it was a civil war
starting today.
I really don't.
He was saying the Democrats are going at
it today.
So somebody shooting somebody.
So who the fuck knows to just to calm
alex down.
Nobody's telling me what to say.
No one's telling me what to do.
I'm not involved in new world order.
Who's the new world?
Just enlightened me about the new.
I'm not sure.
I'm not involved though.
I just want Alex to know.
Not involved.
Who were those people you met the other
day where you get a new world daughter?
Who's the people,
the people you see you eat.
Which Smart,
oh,
these are all podcasters and former
professors and all these different
people that are doing different things
together.
Just scared me the other day though.
Yeah,
on the ropes,
right?
He was taking.
He went back with the CIA.
What are you talking about?
I ain't gonna say nothing either cheaper
too.
It's fourth of July.
Fireworks like fucking CBS Radford,
I think.
I think conspiracies are fun and that's
part of the problem with conspiracies.
They're fun.
They're fun to chase down.
They really are.
They're interests.
I'll tell you what's fun to chase down,
to read about one and to absorb it by
yourself.
Once I get into a room with three men
and we're on a conspiracy for 48
minutes,
that's when I get aggravated.
Well,
that's what I don't ever want to talk
about.
That's what the shit that kills me.
I don't have the time to discuss with
little moon landing or that we all have
an idea of what we think happened.
Guess what?
I really don't want to talk about not on
the fucking fourth of July.
No.
The problem with them is,
and this is a tendency,
is that when people get really into
conspiracy theories,
they're into everything being a
conspiracy.
It's not like they're into conspiracy
theories and also into the history of
Cuba and then give you a detailed
history of some really crazy shit that
went down like how many people that are
really into conspiracy theories could
give you a rundown on how Castro took
over Cuba,
which is like a real thing that happened
in our parents' lifetimes.
Right?
Think about that.
How many people that are really into
like,
you know,
whether or not there's bases on the
moon.
No,
about,
you know,
all these different things that have
happened through human history.
The Mongols,
the Roman Empire,
the Greek camp.
Either this crazy shit that definitely
really happened.
All the stuff that happened during the
Vietnam War,
all the stuff that happened during the
Nixon administration.
All that stuff's real.
It's fascinating,
fascinating shit to look into,
but then you get the dumb ones like,
Oh God,
we really discussed and whether or not
the earth is flat.
Is this a real conversation like people
really doing that satellites aren't real
goal on social media.
You'll find a bunch of people to agree
with you.
Two.
Got To be so careful about not listening
to scientists looked at it with going
Saturday,
Sunday night,
Sunday night on there,
50 years or 60 minutes.
It was showing how they interviewed
different people.
Now the one guy went to some crusade
assignment,
Saddam Hussein's and he said to him,
ask him to tell him that this
guy said he's crazy and the interpreter
looked at him and says,
you,
you think Jerry?
I ain't asked her that and there was
both.
There was one particular interview and
he was just talking about the interview.
He was one of the best interviews he
ever did was when he pushed the guy,
the guy that was standing behind Kennedy
in the car,
the the,
the agent that should have taken the
bullet for Kennedy.
They interviewed that guy.
That's a great.
You got on that one now,
but he was one step behind.
I mean,
he breaks down into tears.
He's a real American,
like this is a guy that's a real
American.
Took that job and then like it wasn't
your fault and he's like,
you don't understand.
I was a second behind.
If I would have been there just one
second earlier,
I would've caught it in my back and the
president would have been a lot.
I mean,
it's fucking crazy.
Jesus.
He imagined being dedicated to protect a
guy with your own life and to really
drink the serum and to believe it like
like a fucking soldier.
Those serves very special human beings
that can do that.
Not a lot of human beings that have that
kind of resolve or throw their life in
front of a bullet to protect someone
else's.
That's intense.
It is intense pain.
You have to hear where the bullet is
coming from,
what your response time as the B to b.
This is when you were real high level
body guard.
This is.
You are the highest of the highest.
You're hearing is impeccable.
This means when you're walking down the
street with this guy inside,
you have to learn by yourself how the
shadow of nature and noises and listened
to footsteps,
weapons,
clicking,
holsters,
opening.
Think of how interesting.
Just that alone is.
That's why sometimes when you see him,
they're holding one ear because there's
zero with anything particular a car's
tires screeching differently.
Think of that fucking job because that's
what their job is to react to that.
So if there's.
If Joe Rogan has eight guys when they
train,
and I don't even know.
I've never trained in Quantico,
but I just know that I think the first
two guys,
the first four guys will lead guys,
they have a mission.
One guy gets to the door.
If there's a shooting,
the other guy ducked.
Two guys buck for the president.
There's got to be planned.
It's like formations and football tunes.
What if the line back,
it goes this way,
you want around me,
just take a fucking genius to tell you
there has to be formation to protect the
president or whoever it is you're
protecting and that level.
When I'm protecting Kevin Hart,
how many people are going to try to
assassinate Kevin Hart when I'm
protecting our president?
How many people are going to really try
to shoot that precedent with weapons?
I mean,
let's go to the Ronald Reagan attempt.
Let's go to these attempts.
How fucking fast this is.
You have to be so high.
He leapt Vietnam,
another war,
and then you had to do a tour with
something else where you would just like
the sport.
You tiptoed in chilled people with
toothpicks and shit.
This is my dream.
This is what I think the training you.
I will think you're just born to be
Rambo.
I think they have to take you to the
government and they start with a hundred
Rambo's.
They just keep training,
training,
training.
You'll lose some along the way and after
every hundred you get eight fucking
savages that never had chance to get
married.
The government never gave him a chance
to get married.
They're that good.
Well,
all these guys that I know that have
been navy seals,
all of them are any special forces guys.
Just you.
Those are different humans,
you know,
to Digitas,
different people,
but what's Jocko navy seal.
Okay.
So in that.
Yeah.
And um,
just just a level that you have to be,
you have to have more control over your
mind,
more control over your will,
more control over your discipline.
You're,
you're in the most elite branch of the
military.
I mean,
this is the elite of the elite money.
Make it insanely difficult to get in.
So you just get the cream of the crops.
The people who are they just a mental
fortitude is just unlike an average
person.
If you meet a bunch of people like that,
man,
you realized like,
wow,
people come in all kinds of different
levels.
There's people that just only surround
themselves with other excellence
and those dudes like those Jocko type
dudes or Tim Kennedy type dudes,
those different kinds of human like you,
they don't make a lot of those.
You just want to have only those boy,
you gotta.
There's a lot that has to happen before
you can become a person like that.
You have to,
you have to travel through many valleys
of the mind.
And the body to get to be a person like
that,
a person have a insane resolve in a time
of war.
It's a very,
very intense human being.
It's not even a time a war.
Look at these 12 Filipino kids in the
fucking back caves down there.
Local went to get them to fucking seals.
The.
The seal team
went down that that would happen.
Well,
there's different various agencies,
but there's also a seal team there.
Makes Sense.
You know the seal team that that's his
elite elite.
So why do you.
I don't even know.
That's how you probably become a fucking
a bodyguard to the president.
You'd have to fucking start like as an
attache somewhere for a year or two with
a suit on.
Just to adjust to human life and life
without fucking Aaron bombs.
Go off every 20 minutes and shit and
then move up in that system until you
get to that level,
the secret service.
There's no way you're going to be a
sick.
They put you to the secret service
training school and you're there in 60
days.
Let me tell you something.
I got my daughter goes to science camp,
you know,
whatever the fuck until pre k starts.
I'm one of the kids.
She goes to his dad's an FBI agent,
so you know,
my job is everyday to sneak up on them
everyday.
Snake upon put a gun to his side,
like what's going on?
Pat Them in the back and he giggles and
shit.
I taught my wife everyday.
He's the worst FBI agent I've ever seen
in my life because I'm too lazy.
Tiptoeing up to him.
He don't even hear me in bushes and
that's how good I am.
Do you know why though?
Because they admire them.
Random and academy today.
Joe Rogan rather the college.
That's why we have so many shootings.
That's why we have so many accidents out
there were police officers.
They don't hire enabled kids anymore.
They hire college graduates that have
never had what we had seen when you were
growing up,
if all else failed,
you've never been arrested in your life.
You really could have been a cop.
You're a nice guy,
but you really could have been killed.
A cop.
You could have been joe the cop in
Quincy,
mass that drives around and shit like
that.
Sure.
Anybody could be.
Anybody could be a class,
but joe,
the cop would have been different if
Joe,
the cop would've came in here and see me
and Jamie argue joe the cop wouldn't
arrest me and Jamie,
Joe,
the cop would say,
I want to meet you motherfuckers
tomorrow.
Retreat will give us both boxing gloves
and we would box so that when we were 12
and both go home and get ice cream the
next day joe,
the cop wouldn't throw.
It was both in jail.
Joe,
the cop wouldn't throw us against a wall
and if we turned around and shoot one of
us in the fucking leg,
he was part of the community.
Joe The cop and Joe on the cop knew what
it was like living in that community as
a child.
Do you understand me?
So,
and I didn't know this.
I've been thinking about a lot of
baptists and I ran into somebody and I
asked them,
why are we having the situation we're
having in this country?
The one last week and fucking East
Pittsburgh is just mind blowing.
That motherfucker just now.
There's a lot of different angles for
that.
They had just finished doing a shoot
out,
but the kid took off this cop watch them
said,
okay God down,
drop down military style.
Blast him three times.
Oh shoot me in the leg,
bitch.
Shoot me in the leg for running away.
That's what joe the cop would do.
Yeah,
but even shooting someone in the leg
away,
what you get,
it's got to be something that they did.
That's really fucked up.
Well listen,
I believe that she showed me some of
them.
Take your fucking life.
I hear Ya.
I'd rather shoot you in the leg then
take your life if it's an iffy call,
but just so you know,
it's not safe to shoot someone in the
leg.
People die from getting shot in the left
ankle.
No.
Okay,
but I'm just mentioning the risk.
I don't want to give anybody the
impression they can just go around
shooting people.
How many movies did we grow up,
but then the guy got shot in the
shoulder.
We just went,
you live getting show miss shaver.
It is.
They get pistol whipped and then when
they wake up it's like nothing happened.
They just start duking it out.
They got pistol whipped.
Everybody was pistol whipping.
People remember that.
They would club them in the head with
the pistol.
That was so crazy.
That was like a thing and then these
people will wake up.
Why?
What happened?
I didn't get pistol whipped with the but
I got pistol whipped with the gun to the
head.
Nothing blood,
thank God,
but if fucking hurt,
I don't know what the fuck type of gun.
It was like an automatic,
like a,
like a nine millimeter tighten.
It wasn't like a revolver.
I never got hit with the bud or what a
weird feature of the human body.
If you hit it in the right spots,
it goes out.
We have like a plug.
We have like a loser,
like some people's plugs.
A little looser than others.
Some people's plugs like Mark Hunt.
It takes forever to knock it loose.
Some people could just take it,
some people can't.
It's fucking weird.
So weird characteristic hit people.
And they go unconscious.
It's very strange.
It's very strange feature that we
exploit,
you know,
but movies,
they always make it like it's no big
deal.
It's a big fucking deal.
It's a big deal.
You should avoid having it done to you.
It's a big deal to get knocked
unconscious.
You know,
it's so weird.
When we first started hanging out one
afternoon,
you took me to see that boxing coach at
the time he had four academy award.
God as he was training.
Was that Terry Clay Bond try reclaimed
Monteith.
Terry's amazing.
He's a great guy.
We walked in there,
we went upstairs and I,
I think uh,
at the time when we walked the Nicholas
cage is up there at the time,
was a piece on his shit at the bar and
stuff.
And then Terry came over and gave you a
hug and we went downstairs and tyree
grab Steve Simone later on because Steve
worked there at the time.
This is 97,
98 as a gym.
And he goes,
boy,
that guy's in the wrong profession.
As a comic,
he should've been a boxy.
It's like a meal,
you know.
And I never forgot that him saying that
and all the stuff you talk about brain
damage and and whatever,
it took a lot for you that at that age
to realize that this was fucking for
real.
This was,
this was dangerous.
There was no money in it.
There was no temptation.
This head,
this head shit is not.
This is real.
It was real.
But it was also a.
I didn't have any temptation.
Now what happened before this?
Like what happened to the guys that I
saw playing football and black and white
with leather helmets.
Well,
you know,
leather helmets are safer,
believe it or not because you don't feel
as confident.
When they had those leather helmets,
it didn't crash into each other the same
way.
There's a,
there's a opinion.
I don't know if I agree with it because
I don't know much about the sport,
but there's an opinion that no pads,
no helmets,
football would be safer because you
wouldn't be able to do the same things
that they're doing now.
You can't just run into people head to
head.
You just just destroy you and you can
only do it a few times.
Your body will start breaking,
but if you're putting helmets on and
pads,
it accentuates your ability to run into
someone with all your force that's
unnatural and it creates an unnatural
jarring of the body and the brain that
the rugby guys don't get.
The rugby guys don't have all those
paths,
so when they're clashing into each
other,
they're learning how to roll with things
and not just colliding into each other.
They're not.
There's a different game when you've got
padding,
so if you take away the padding,
people have to be more careful and how
they're engaged.
They can't just charge in and smash into
each other.
They won't last.
I always cte the game context sport for
sure.
Getting banged up.
It's a contact sport context.
Are there any.
Don't know.
Interesting fun though.
I remember being a kid.
I'm from New Jersey.
It's a real good question.
And fucking Jersey,
right?
Yeah,
we know football.
I didn't even go to soccer back then
when I lived in Jersey through soccer's
a couple of Spanish people,
played the dark side of the court.
It played soccer on Sundays.
They will even let.
Nobody wants me,
a couple of Spanish guys.
But besides that,
soccer was not
begging my area.
But uh,
when I moved to Aspen I would go to the
hospital on Saturday just to walk around
and get a big of the sandwich and I'd
see rugby.
I had never saw that.
I didn't even know what the fuck it was
and I was like,
I'm in good shape.
And after about three times I went,
one of the guys at I want you to show up
on a fucking Saturday.
And I looked at them like,
what are you crazy?
Like,
I don't even know what the fuck you guys
are doing.
They have a big rug rug fest in Aspen
every year,
pretty much every year.
That's where I first saw rugby was in
Colorado.
I don't think you've ever seen it live.
I've only seen it on TV.
No,
I've seen it live,
but it's,
you know,
I saw three,
I saw two things that blew me away live
and in Colorado I saw rugby and I saw
when they did like a tour de France star
type race,
but they did it sludge snowmass village
and I knew exactly what it was the road
up and how we would have to be a circle
to go by and you didn't have to go back
down to rule to would just do circles
around snowmass and I still remember
being on a hill,
listening to them going up the hill and
it just blew my fucking mind the way the
tire was hitting the speeds,
like how fast they were going uphill and
then 20 years later you realize that
doing ppo and fucked and hanging out
with Sheryl Crow's though husband
shooting all that shit.
Can you imagine when they were shooting
in the eighties when I saw him,
Jesus was shit stronger back then.
I can only imagine what's the drug that
they shoot at.
The legs won't stop moving at night.
So they got a gun on a bicycle.
Oh,
epo.
It's not the delay,
the blood gets thick apparently,
I'm probably saying it wrong,
but uh,
they have this feeling like they have to
exercise.
One of our buddies was a biker and you
know,
he was professional tour guide,
just like,
you know,
not like a super famous super successful
one,
but he was a professional bike rider.
What would you call one of those
cyclists?
Professional cyclists.
And he would tell us about it,
how guys you'd hear them.
He knew that they were on epo and then
you would hear them when they were on a
tour bus.
They'd get up in the middle of the night
and go ride their bike.
Like they felt like they had to
exercise.
So I guess if you're on a lot of it,
I don't know,
I've never done it.
It seems like it would be awesome
though,
if you could take some drug that like
super juiced up your endurance.
That sounds awesome.
But apparently it's just not very safe.
And there were saying that um,
a lot of executives take it now.
Like there's,
there's people that are executives that
are just entering endurance races and
they're taking epo and entering into
these endurance races that like regular
people with regular jobs just decided to
take it.
There was some article about that,
see if he could find it.
It was like Ceos,
uh,
entering into an endurance races taking
epo,
but it's a few fighters.
I'm been caught with it and it
apparently just really juices up your
urine.
You go 16 rounds instead of fucking type
shit.
Yeah.
I had a friend that used to shoot me
steroids and never do a pushup.
Jesus Christ,
he was whacked.
That's crazy dog.
When are you going to go to the gym?
Next week?
That's same.
I'll never forget seeing him eat like
half a bottle
of Winnie v,
the pink football.
Like the pink ones in the eighties.
He would just put them into this.
I'm like,
pick the X.
would it be a Oh my God,
tomorrow did some pushups today.
Just my biceps.
That's all I need.
A few biceps.
A talions crazy group of humans that
came out of always wanting you to do the
impersonation from you.
When the Italian people in Jersey.
From that,
that Marlon Brando is gay.
I can't fucking believe in 20 years he
was the godfather and no,
no,
no.
He couldn't blow a regular dude.
No.
God forbid he blows a black dude really
stabbed me right here and the fuck they
lot.
I couldn't even take it no more.
I had to throw the DVD collection away
and fucking.
I would love to hear one of those guys.
What they said.
They found that,
that that week,
didn't they say that he fucked
everybody?
Men and women.
He banged.
Everybody fucked everybody.
Yeah,
and then it came out.
He was banging the guy with the big Dick
and cube.
That's right.
Superman.
That's so fucking poor Italian people.
If that godfather fans,
they will lighten those fucking dvds on
five.
Fuck.
Marlon Brando.
Poor.
Poor homophobes.
I like them more now.
I like Marlon Brando Brando.
Yeah.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't listen to me.
Richard.
Prior to thinking about Richard Pryor
getting so coked up that he lit Marlon
Brando fucker was one of the things I
was like,
unless he that's prejudice with me,
I should just assume he enjoyed it and I
assume he enjoyed having sex with a
brand.
Why should I give a shit?
Listen to the first number one thing,
because you're going to die when I tell
you this.
Oh,
Marlin Brando.
Talk to studio and to give them like 100
grand to read superman.
Like you know when people call you up
Joe.
Hi Joe.
This is Cynthia from your agents,
right?
We're sending you a script over to
approved to read.
Yeah,
hundred grand.
Give me a hundred grand and I'll reduce
it because he went to the island.
He went deep and he believed his ego.
You got to remember that was an all time
record for a long time.
When he got Super Mad,
he banged him out.
He took them to the cleanest time.
Shoot him.
He fucked them up in the ass.
Bad.
My big find that what they pay them in
1970 whatever for Superman member,
he fucked them big time.
Um,
I think it's mutiny on the bounty and
one of those movies they kept saying,
Oh,
we have a beautiful spot for you right
here in little marina though,
right?
If we do this,
we'll do this on this island.
My phone,
he had gone down there from La.
He's like,
there's a bunch of running around.
There's a bunch of women running around
with leaves on it.
No damage.
I didn't do that.
He made the studio shoot down there then
and then went down there.
Who wants to go to the fucking?
Whatever island they shot that.
So that's where he lived.
Right.
So he went down there,
he got down and he's like,
Jamie,
which your job pa no more either
director Rogan,
you're this.
And everybody was shooting.
They were shooting his feet.
They were shooting him rotten and like
the shore and meanwhile he was just
banging fucking Hawaiian when either the
time this happened.
Oh,
gas bagging kids.
All those kids that shop themselves,
all those kids he had no more.
Oh my God,
those poor kids that fucking God rest
his soul that all those problems he had,
he was down there like fucking just
matador and whatever paramont whether
the network was showed up,
down and so let's see the dailies and
said,
what the fuck is this?
You're done.
They brought somebody else in.
Malden ended up saying,
fuck it,
I'll buy the island he bought the
island.
Didn't need like,
this is just crazy shit.
I heard over the years and they just
lived on the island and then if they
wanted to have a quality island and they
have like levels or you want me to read
the script?
That's what,
of course she had.
Oh you want me to come to the studio?
That's $300,000.
But he had levels of fucking and they
would give it to them.
They will.
And then they didn't want him for the
Godfather.
They were like,
Nah,
there's no way we want that fucking guy.
Wow.
And then finally he put the tape in his
mouth and all that shit.
And they approved them and he didn't
know that movies like a point to one.
He did that last tango in Paris isn't,
that's like a light porn and then the
chick came out.
He just laid there and said that
motherfucker stone cold rape me.
He.
Yeah,
he was the king of me too.
He invented me too.
That motherfucker dog.
Wow.
Yeah.
She came out years later and said
something about she didn't know what
Marlon Brando went in there and choked
her out like mcqueen and fucking and the
getaway.
She thought she was just getting pushed.
You had the mcqueen and who was with
him?
That was hard to watch,
Dude,
because you could tell that was real.
There's no way that wasn't real.
Like he was really hitting her and let
her know he was a method actor is harsh.
He's crazy.
He was crazy.
Scene was so real because of it.
I mean it's awful to watch but.
But it's real,
right?
It's an awful scene.
It's real fuck man.
That you imagine being her and all of a
sudden that do just start smacking you
in the head for real.
You don't know what to do and you don't
want to bail out of the scene.
You're getting fucked up though.
He fucking you up and she didn't stop.
She just kept saying the lines and
working with it.
Fuck Dude.
Jesus Christ.
What do you say to somebody after that
game?
And I'm sorry,
but that's what the scene call for
you can't see out of peep for it sounds
fucked up to say,
but I think even just that recent time,
people did not understand that if you're
smacking people in the head like that,
you're giving them fucking brain damage.
Like you smack someone in the head like
that.
Like you could seriously fucked them up.
Like something could be wrong with them
for a long time.
Even if they don't go unconscious.
Your mother is Maggie?
No,
no.
My mom wasn't a or really?
No,
she wasn't a head.
Which Matthew,
that very few people.
Uncle.
No,
very few people.
I'll tell you,
it won't be my grandmother cracked me
once,
but it was,
you know,
just like get your shit together.
Not like trying to hurt me,
you know,
just a little smack.
I didn't get beat as a kid.
But uh,
I saw a lot of violence.
I saw the scene violence when you were a
kid.
There's something about like seeing
someone you're close to who is an adult
be beating up like a 10 or 11 year old.
You ever see that before?
When you see,
when you see somebody that you ever see
a grown adult beaten the shit out of a
10 or 11 year old when you're a little
kid?
Yes.
That to me was.
That was like a defining moment when I
was a little kid as a parent or I only
show a parents beat the children.
Yeah.
I saw someone beat somebody else's kid.
It was fucked up to watch man
when I lived on 200,
five west,
88th street.
We can't.
When I came from Cuba,
we live in New Jersey for him.
My Dad died at 89th street.
Then something happened at the building.
We ended up moving to 88th street and
they had a kid I had a beef with every
day and one day I finally got my shit
together and karate
like one day on my side kickstart at
working and that fucking right cross
started working to learn how to use my
fucking block and I finally had this
kid.
His name was rudy,
the Haitian.
He was the only Haitian kid in the
neighborhood.
We lived on 88th street and I fucked
them up this day and his father came
down and held my arms and he made rudy
punched me and I'll never forget that my
lip was bleeding and he took me upstairs
and knocked on my mother's door and my
mother opened up the door and half a
fucking angle and she goes,
what's the problem?
She goes out with Coco,
you know,
and he goes,
next time you sun hits my son,
I'm going to hit him.
And I'm like,
come on you.
My mom turned around and got a butcher
knife and chased rudy's.
Fall up the stairs,
chops claim and the lady next door.
So she didn't see a knife,
but at that point we were done in the
building.
Geez.
That was one of the worse there.
When I moved to North Bergen,
I saw parents that you don't like.
You ever hear a comedian go hang out
with white kids?
He wasn't a house.
How they talked to their parents.
I could never talk to about.
You know,
that's the first thing I noticed when I
went to jersey,
there was,
there were certain kids that will take
the addition go,
I don't want to fish sandwich.
If I ever did that in my house.
Joe Rogan are you fucking kidding me?
My mom would take the dish,
throw it against the wall and say,
now you're not fucking eat and go to
bed.
Like that type of shit.
But I also saw a fucking parent in the
hallway one day I was standing in the
way.
You are with his arms crossed.
Torque them to the teacher the way I'm
talking to you.
And a kid standing right here with
glasses on.
And I'm walking towards him like,
you know,
I went to the bathroom and like a hall
pass and I'm talking,
talking,
and in the middle of it,
the father just going back and hitting
them with a backhand kick goes down,
glasses,
broken.
Blood's coming out of the nose.
Oh please tell them to get the fuck up
before I fucking kill you.
You dumb mother fucker.
Oh,
you said that to him.
You dumb.
Fuck.
I have seen that.
Oh,
that kid was the devil.
I know that kid.
Well,
the reason why they can't get Kim's the
devil probably because his dad beat him.
And then there was another kid when I
went to Catholic school,
we know Father Ginzo the whole fucking
thing,
bro.
He would come that the nicest guy in the
world.
But the sun was fucking crazy.
And every time he get there,
the nun would tell him about what he did
and dog.
He would punch him the way.
Old Guy always throwing punches.
Guy fucking Steve Bay.
I switched rooms.
Was griff right as he was crawling into
the car like a frown.
Pounded them 12.
Jesus,
I got thrown out of that 11.
So now are you looking at me saying Joey
did they deserve it or whatever.
Everybody,
every parent had a different,
uh,
you know,
I watched a couple of weeks ago I was
stung to the gills and I was laughing
about how people put people down and
shit.
And I was laughing about when Julia
serving first when the Aba shut down,
when the Aba for a shut down,
if they were,
I don't know Joe,
but if there was eight categories,
Julius Irving's lead seminars and the
Aba shut down and the six is picked up.
Julia serving.
They gave him $6,000,000,
which can you imagine that?
What would they give that guy yet?
What they give Le Bron?
Ron's getting about 30 or 40,
but yet he got $6,000,000
over two years or that was Julius and
he was the biggest play in the world
that now this guy's getting 1:54
for three cheeses.
So Dr Jay switches number from 32 to six
and now the NBA All star game came.
So all the critics were like,
he came from the Aba,
he's gonna,
get his ass kicked in the NBA All star
game.
What?
Go look at those statistics.
He went off,
he went off because I'm a white dude
named Pistol Pete Maravich.
That is.
He went to Lsu and lead the country in
scoring a white dude and ended up
becoming a fucking booze about that dude
knew how to handle the ball because his
father would beat him.
His father would make him sleep in the
garage and the winter and beat him until
he learned how to play basketball
because there was no losing in this
fucking house.
Do you understand me,
Joe Rogan?
No.
Fucking my fucking house.
Sleep in the garage.
No data pistol.
Pete knew how to dribble jacket with a
pistol.
Pete would take you deep pistol.
Pete can.
Anybody could cover by the best black
dude in the league and cover pistol
pete.
But if you watch the NBA All star Game
Pistol Pete stomping chomping people and
give them behind the back passes to
Julius Irving.
He even looks at a do a one path.
He's looking at Bob Mcadoo.
I'm coming,
I don't think just puts the ball between
his legs and he gives it to Julia
serving.
Why?
Because that kid's father stayed on.
There's different thoughts of some
people can handle that.
Some people have to like some.
Some guys are broken,
but I mean it's like how much pressure
is too much pressure to create like a
superstar like that.
I didn't.
Tiger Woods didn't.
His Dad put a lot of pressure on him as
well.
It was.
Now let's talk about the.
The guy that died last week,
but that's a different thing I can tell.
Well,
the tiger woods,
Joe Jackson.
What the fuck is different about that?
He created three fucking kids that
changed the fucking one kid that change
the fucking world.
He beat on me.
Fuck them in the ass.
Opposed to.
I don't know.
He did sexual assault.
One.
Got To be really careful with the same
things.
I'm sorry.
Listen this to me.
Two things.
Things come out.
What are you going to do?
Everybody's getting the blame for
something.
You know what I'm saying?
But this is something you really heard.
I have heard sexual abuse allegations
from his father,
but,
but I listen to what,
listen to what did he create,
what do they do?
What did Joe Jackson do by making them
not letting them fucking and,
and let me tell you something to one kid
could have gone to a college to play
basketball.
The kids had talent as it was gary,
Indiana ever go to carry and then.
No,
it's like hell
a fucking Delaware.
And then Gary,
Indiana,
like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like Gary's like crazy.
He made these kids for her.
She pulled them out of Gary,
took him up to fucking Berry Gordy,
you know,
you think about this shit.
Some of them probably hated him for what
he did.
You look back at those lessons that you
got Joe Rogan.
How many people did you look at one day
and go,
fuck you motherfucker.
But then two years later you look back
and you look at the lesson you learned
from the whole experience and you
actually have to go back and hug that
person and go,
hey man,
thank you for that time.
It made me better motherfucker tonight.
Because what you did made me a better
person will have to agree with
everything that happens along the way.
Joe wrote,
but it's maintenance.
Who the fuck we are today?
That's an interesting thing because we
grew up in a time where kids were just
allowed to run around outside.
Everybody ran around outside.
That was just normal.
Right.
When you were a little kid,
you ran around outside.
Nobody just runs around outside.
I remember the first time I saw a grown
lady hit.
She hit my cousin.
We were both around the same age.
I was probably six and she was five and
this lady slipped on ice in front of her
apartment building and she got up and my
cousin just unfortunately happened to be
standing right in front of her when she
fell and she got up and she said,
don't you laugh at me?
And she smacked her in the face.
She wasn't laughing at her either.
Just she smashed her in the face,
man like it was.
She smacked her hard and I was like,
oh my God.
Was that we were both little,
little kids and watching some grown
adults smash our cousin in the face real
like
like,
hey,
you can't you,
you know,
you gotta be polite.
There's some fucking people that was
smack you in the face and she didn't
even do anything wrong.
Here's some evil fuckers out there
that'll hit little kids.
That's a dark shit man.
Smack and little kids in the face.
I swear to God.
I read into probably when I first moved
from Cuba,
but to Ada street,
there was a dude on the block that would
smack the little kids and I'm telling
you right now to my little daughter that
was words on the street that he would
take it through his house and fuck you
the ass.
Oh my goodness.
That is that early 70 [inaudible].
This was the early seventies,
which I turned into a joke later on
because it would be like,
Bro,
have you seen Joe Rogan lately?
I haven't seen them in a week.
Sticky Charlie go like,
what was his name?
Mr Martinez.
Mr Martinez the Martini Guy.
Like when you first moved to 88th
street.
That's the first and the kid to tell you
like,
I will you this guy.
Don't fuck them,
Mr.
Martini.
Oh Jesus.
He's a monster and it's nearby.
Kenny wore a black suit with a white
shirt and black shoes.
His wife would die and he owned the
building at Eighth Street in the middle
and he was angry and he would sweep and
you know,
like when you were a kid and you stop in
front of somebody's house,
he would always come out and go get the
fuck outta here.
You little fucking Douche bags.
Get the.
And I was Cuban.
I didn't understand the language.
I didn't really understand what he was
saying.
I understood the anger,
but other than understanding the
language and they will come out with a
broom,
get the fuck out of here.
One day I realized I'm like,
this motherfucker wants to rock.
So while my other friends didn't want to
fuck with him,
I'm like,
we're going to fuck with this
motherfucker.
So all humans have at like one in front
of their house and there's something
that your mother's role is changing
every day.
Good luck.
Statue.
And I would steal the change and bring
it downstairs and I will look at the
poor kids and I go,
come in,
if there's anything you want to call it.
And they would go,
yeah,
we'll get a quarter.
I would take a quarter and throw it with
Mr.
Martini lived.
He lived like in a basement area.
He ran the whole bit.
He'd be right there and he chased us.
We'd go Mr Matine something like weaning
and fucking chases chases caught yet he
would fucking hit you like 50 times.
But we fucked him up.
We would fuck him up dog.
I saw some shit the first day like New
Jersey to me.
Was it completely?
That was like Mars to most people,
like most people listening to me and go,
you grew up someplace that doesn't
exist.
I'll bring eight people,
throw these chairs to tell you about the
parents and the people and the
situations.
But the first day I went out in my
hometown,
I'm up Bergen.
I saw me and Joe Rogan fight.
And even though I had Joe Rogan on his
back,
I saw Joe Rogan's father come down the
stairs.
Pulled me off.
Joe Rogan smack me,
punched me.
He kicked me,
throw me on the floor and make this kid
go in.
That was my first experience ever.
North Bergen,
New Jersey.
I saw Mr Robson come downstairs.
He took anthony off.
His son drew him off.
She smacked him in the fucking face.
Joe Rogan had two half after fucking
noon in 90 degree.
He punched him in the stomach and told
them to go home.
You Little Guinea,
fuck,
go home.
You Little Guinea.
Fuck.
Say that now they'll throw you in jail
for two years.
He told them,
go home,
you go to Guinea.
Fuck.
And Anthony looked at him crying a
little bit.
He picked up his shirt.
He went like this,
like he took the thing off.
I think it was unclear on my fucking
father.
You're fucking dead.
Motherfucker.
Call Your fucking Guinea fucking
greaseball father.
God I,
he's probably a grease ball just like
you.
And I'm sitting there going,
I want to see how this plays out.
And next thing you know,
two cop cars pull up and it's one cop
car that's unmarked.
It's another one that's marked and it's
a big fucking Italian looking detective
like you know the,
the short stumpy paddling and he comes
out of his car.
He puts his fucking jacket on.
It barely fits,
but till this day I remember the more
the dowels he had on his hand and he
goes,
what the fuck's going on here?
Kids?
And the little Italian kid completely
goes missing the fucking Mr.
Robinson came down and he fucking smack
me in the face.
These are my witnesses.
Then he fucking hit me and I'm sitting
there going,
oh,
this is going to get fucking good.
Then next thing you know the,
the fucking cop,
the detective tells the cop,
go look around and see if there's
tickets.
Go spread tickets.
And he goes,
where's the sky live?
yeah.
And he goes,
and he grabbed all the other kids and he
goes,
tell me what happened.
And he goes,
anthony and him were fighting and he
came down here and he fucking pulled him
and that this time they know that the
cops are there.
And Mr Robson,
I kind of opened this door to be kind of
tough,
like he's not coming up where he's on
the normal fucking knock came up to and
the cop goes,
okay,
okay.
And he grabbed the kid and he goes,
you're okay,
right?
Yeah.
And he goes,
he just hit me in the face and he
fucking walked up the stairs.
Brown took come five minutes,
got to the top thing.
I opened the fucking door.
Joe Rogan.
This guy will put his hand.
Then he pulled the fucking put them
against the fucking thing on the second
floor with everybody out and just
started punching him,
punching him,
punching him like fucking John June.
It's one of these,
got you're down.
He's hitting you with those shots to the
head until the guy killed over and they
started kicking him with the fucking
thing.
Bam,
Bam.
And he goes,
don't you ever fucking hit my son again?
Let's get outta here.
Or that was how I became friends with
the family because as soon as he came
down,
he goes,
who's this kid?
He goes,
he's good.
He's the only one that jumped in.
He goes,
you want to come home for dinner?
And that was the beginning of my life
when I got in that police car.
Wow.
Because I did whatever I did.
Whatever the fuck I want to look at this
until today.
This is fucking crazy.
And you know me and you don't fuck
around with.
He got over there.
This is still,
that's what happened in 1970 fucking
three and once that today that's.
I'll go the car.
What is this car to do it.
It does what?
It will need it to do.
It does whatever I needed to do.
You know what I'm saying?
You're a family member.
Why?
Because of that fucking day because I'm
the only guy that jumped in.
I like how cops have things like that.
A family member have a card you can get
from one of your buddies who's a cop
show.
Do you ever get pulled over and put this
on your license plates?
A little sneaky little thing.
So now what type of meeting the house.
I'm eating fucking pasta with fresh
Mozzarella in the middle.
Oh,
I could open up the front door,
whatever I wanted.
I called the mom,
mom.
She makes cream pops.
Oh Wow.
I'm tight with them.
I'm the only Cuban in 1974.
Let's even walking in there.
So now we're in the sixth grade and
we're playing kickball.
Can Lee had no,
fucking remember two months ago I wanted
to generously donated 50,000
to a grammar school.
Was my grandma's school North Bergen?
New Jersey a couple months ago?
Yeah.
I wanted to.
Genesis donated $50,000
when I went to that grammar school was
motherfuckers didn't have a gym.
Joe Rogan.
You shovel snow.
They're going to be
shoveled.
Snow shoveled snow.
When it snowed out,
you shovel snow.
That was part of your physical education
and you did pushups and sit ups and
fucking Russian Shit Bro.
And they had a bar in the kitchen.
We didn't know they were brutal.
Finally they built a gym in the eighth
grade.
Yeah,
but before that we played kickball
outside in the fall.
One day will king playing kickball,
and I forget this guy's name was Mr
Laura.
That was the teacher's name.
Was he a good guy?
It was a little gym,
PJ and we're out there and we're playing
kickball and again,
that little Italian kid,
the one that invited me,
there was four other dude.
We're playing kickball and he's throwing
the ball and every time I swing and I
miss,
he's calling me Gacaca.
That means I'm a boogie face in Spanish
because it rhymes a coco.
Right.
And the teacher keeps going.
But a,
I told you a thousand times,
none of that SPEC sheets allowed.
This is the sixth grade North Bergen,
New Jersey school teacher.
Mr [inaudible] was like,
Hey,
none of that shit over here.
Right?
This is America.
Really?
That was at that time.
That was a big issue because a couple
weeks before that,
a guy named Portora was a baseball coach
and he threw a kid off for speaking
Spanish on the bus.
He told me there's no Spanish on the
bus,
and the kid goes,
fuck you.
Or they spoke Spanish.
They threw them off like 20 miles from
the house.
Became a big problem in my hometown.
They're going to kill the fucking dude,
but I remember going home,
my mom going,
he's talking to the truth
and now she speaks Spanish.
This is America outside.
You speak American.
So my mom cut me off right there.
Like I went home,
like ready to fucking be like a
protestor.
She was like,
that don't happen here.
We're Americans.
He wants to expand.
It's totally like the house.
I think there's a real benefit to being
able to speak more than one language.
Definitely is complete different
mindset.
I'm happy I do it.
I speak to my daughter in Spanish.
If I tell him I asked him mercy,
something.
I reasked her in Spanish.
If I read,
I read tyler and spread.
Nice.
Yeah.
They say that things like that they're
learning new languages in particular
opens up parts of your brain that if
you're just a dummy like me that only
speaks English.
You can access different.
Just different ways of looking at
things,
you know?
Well,
it's very analytical.
Say you wanted
to be a lawyer,
one of your pre.
Whatever would be a language,
right?
You'd also have a heavy math to be a
lawyer,
you have to have a very heavy math
prereq.
Iom.
Yeah,
a lot of history.
You probably ended up being a history
major,
but there'd be a lot of math while the
economy,
a lot on the analytics because it forces
your mind to solve equations,
so when,
if you look at the prerequisites,
if you whatever the fuck it is,
what is the glue?
Requisites.
Prerequisites to be an attorney.
It was a lot of math involved.
Interesting.
There's got to be the language involved.
There's got to be politics involved,
American political systems,
American history systems,
all that shit,
but it's got to be heavy math once you
get the law.
School was heavy reading and.
But before that,
it's a lot of problem solving.
Yeah,
that's the.
That's how you become a problem solver
by fucking whatever.
Yeah,
I agree with you.
Whatever you just said,
but before I got locked up,
I was planning to be an attorney,
so I was really.
I'm a history major.
Yeah,
that's that.
That was the fucking plan.
And then history,
podcasts.
I love them.
They're the best.
I was thinking of going back to school.
No,
no,
no.
There's no reason.
Just listening and refresh and then go
on and read about it,
but that you listen to the great but a
hardcore history and ever listing my boy
Daniel de la history on fire.
His Shit.
It's fantastic.
He was telling me about this road to
Rome.
I've never forgot this image where there
was I think something like a hundred and
50 miles of bodies that were put on
steaks.
He sent it to me.
He just sounded to me a couple of days
ago,
hundred and 50 miles of of human bodies
that they stuck on these big poles and
shoved him into the ground for like for
my,
like every 30 yards,
they put a new person's body.
Here it is.
One hundred 25 miles with one body
crucified every 30 yards or so for a
total of about 6,000
people crucified on the road between
Capua and Rome.
What the fuck now?
What was your purpose?
I would have to go back and listen to it
again.
I forgot.
Sansa,
Shalom rather here.
Whew.
That's shit's intense.
I want to start with.
I'm going to start from zero.
I'm going to start with the Mongolians
and go listen.
Wrath of the con Dan Carlin greatest
podcast world ever.
And then I want to move on to American
history.
Oh,
he's the one I need to.
American history one.
Oh,
one day one.
We're going back to the roots.
Let's go from roots.
Let's go to 17,
76.
What happened all there?
I need all that.
Refresh.
Yeah.
All that stuff needs to be refreshed.
Do Carla and guy has got some stuff on
world war one that's covered both wars
was covered.
Both wars.
Let's cover the third war.
Vietnam and let's cover the fucking
whatever the conflict.
All that shit.
I was doing comedy so he watches the
news.
I don't know who the fuck was watching
the news in 1991.
Not Me.
I didn't watch TV again until 2003 or
something like that and watch the
fucking news and have a chance to be
inclined politically or what the fuck
was going on.
I was just worried about doing standup.
Right.
This silence brought to you by marijuana
or.
I didn't.
No,
no,
no.
I didn't know.
I thought he was looking for something
or whatever.
Or I'm ready to fucking go.
You know,
we've got a great fucking card.
Just fucking breakdown.
Now.
You broke it down with Brendan.
I gotta tell you man,
I like.
I'm leaning and I love Dan male.
He's a fucking champions.
The champions.
He took a fucking couple bombs from
Anthony Johnson bomb,
Samantha Johnson,
but Jesus Christ,
every time they put an obstacle in front
of steep based way,
he figures out a way to take it down.
You know,
he's hell bent on staying champion.
He's a giant dude like steep pays a big
guy and I know that Daniel has beaten
every single heavyweight.
He's fought.
He's undefeated as a heavyweight and
including like throwing Josh Barnett
around who's just a beast,
but a steep pays a as the most
accomplished heavyweight champion of all
time.
That's just a fact.
He defended his title against the top
contenders and did it successfully three
times.
Nobody else been able to do that.
Okay,
good.
Holloway.
Jesus Christ.
When we fight both fights or Jesus,
man,
a DC fight is a fascinating,
fascinating fight to it.
So funny.
Nominal wrestler and steep a is.
I mean he's as good as it gets.
You're doing the show Friday night?
Yeah,
we're doing.
Me and Ian are doing the Mirage.
Okay,
beautiful.
Yeah.
Should be fun.
Nice.
You ready for it?
Yeah man.
I'm excited.
I'm excited for this card.
It should be.
It should be very interested in what's
going on with you and the running
lately.
You're really digging it.
Yeah,
I'm digging it,
but I have a little bit of a tear in my
meniscus.
Are you thinking of if you fix them in
this case of doing something with
running,
like running,
but your buddy does those marathons?
Oh No.
Have you considered something like that
or not really,
man,
I'm not.
I don't.
I'm not into doing something that I know
is hard to do and it's definitely not
good for your body.
I just think you get beat up doing that
shit.
Tomlin was just take your friend.
I mean as good as Shannon.
Different kinds of human.
Well,
he believes that in some ways they take
them to recover from something that.
Well,
that's an interesting thing.
You just a good good time for that
question because he just ran a race
today.
He ran like a six mile race and he was
saying that his legs are not fully
recovered.
Who was saying in the post that,
you know,
his cardio was really good,
but you got to figure you run for 24
hours.
I mean he ran for 24 hours just a month
ago,
right?
Was it a month ago?
Not even a month ago,
three weeks ago.
Something like that.
Um,
that shit takes time and he's 50,
you know,
when you're 50 years old,
it's not as a recovery is that.
Recovery is very tough.
He's an animal.
He lives to push himself like that.
I'm more inclined to try to preserve my
body.
I like pushing myself,
but I'm just a chicken shit.
I don't want to be,
I don't want to be breaking hips and
knees and shit.
Our brother just had shoulder surgery,
Eddie Bravo and he just got the stitches
out.
This is his second surgery that he's had
just this year,
you know,
he had um,
he had knee surgery real recently,
like a few months ago,
right?
Didn't he have his meniscus done a few
months ago?
This generation of Jujitsu guys is
learning a lot and they're learning what
they're going to pass on to the next
generation is that it's great to roll.
The lego blocks are great at all.
That is great.
But there's another aspect to this.
Disposition was called yoga and keeping
your muscles strong conditioning has to
be good.
And your,
uh,
you know,
there's just take care of yourself.
These,
these guys didn't.
No,
you didn't.
no,
no.
Well,
it took a while to learn.
But the reality of Jujitsu is it's a
thing that as you get older you have to
be much more careful who you trained
with and how you train.
You can't just go balls to the wall like
you could when you were 27.
You have to keep your shit together and
you know,
injuries are real.
You can't just work through them.
Like that was a big fallacy.
People would get hurt and they would try
to roll light and nobody ever rose
light.
Then we say they're gonna roll light and
then the guy almost gets you in.
Then you're trying to get him.
Next thing you know you're defending and
it's fucking serious.
Heated up roll session,
which is great.
But then you're like,
ah,
like you're next.
All fucked up.
And you go,
all right,
next guy.
I'm just going to lay on my back at
work.
My half guard bullshit.
As soon as it starts getting hot and
heavy,
almost got caught in an arm bar.
They didn't try to pop up,
but then try to pass his guard.
Then you get into it.
You know,
it's a,
it's a thing that's exciting,
you know,
and she jitsu.
Uh,
and when I say rolling hard,
I don't mean like,
not even.
No,
no,
no.
Listen to me passing your garden and lay
it on you.
That's tough.
That's a tough morning.
Even though I'm giving you love on top
joke and you breathe.
Yeah.
I'm good Joe.
I'm letting you get the book.
I will give tons of love it.
I love it.
Yeah,
addicted to it.
It's changed who I am,
you know,
I had an attack from a different
foundation.
I was attacking it from looking at Jamie
and going,
I got to do what Jamie does and not
realizing I got Jamie by 25 years and I
can't do what Jamie does.
So my game has to be completely
different to Jamie's Mondays when I come
into class,
it's more about the,
uh,
the,
the uh,
drilling less about the rolling and I'll
do an hour conditioning class with
bread.
We do everything.
We do the ball things,
the ropes.
I do everything and I'll do that Jujitsu
class,
but I'll do the drills are roll once or
twice and papa's got to go Thursday.
I go balls to the wall on the roaming,
which means three or four role.
That's awesome.
And then I tried to take Friday off and
Saturday I'll do and conditioning and
I'm done for the week.
Joey Diaz getting fit.
You got to do it.
I got this five year old,
number two,
I watched your thing and I really do it.
I go to fucking crowd therapy and I put
my head in that I got a US cryotherapy.
I'm a Novus or guy to that bed is making
me feel fucking phenomenal.
What is it?
I'm getting tremendous Harlan's.
The Nova thought bed.
The bed that you lay on,
it cleans out yourselves and shit like
that.
Do it.
Does everything look it up?
You understand me?
Plus I get in that freezer for three
minutes and 30 seconds.
I put Madonna.
Burn enough you love.
And what?
The Gay Pride.
I forgot all about the gate center.
Fitter.
Healthier,
happier.
What is it?
Tremendous job doing it.
They're going to talk us into getting
into a pod and next thing you know
you're going to be locked into the.
Into the Matrix.
What?
So what is this treatment?
No negative side effects clients or
supply supplied with safety goggles and
then relax into Novo Thor treatment prod
for eight to 15 minutes of whole body
restorative light treatment.
The treatment maybe repeated two or more
times a week.
What is it?
Doing something what it's done,
but like what does the instigate the
fucking the other look into before,
but tell me why I should get your light
box.
It's a whole body delivery system of PBM
therapy that has been designed to
deliver optimum wave lengths power.
What does that word?
Densities and dosages based on the
published clinical research outcomes.
Huh?
I can't read.
For me it works the whole body,
just six slash 15 minutes.
The intended use of Nova thor or to
redevelop muscles or restore motion to
joints or for use as an adjunct therapy
for obesity.
That seems like it does a lot of shit.
I don't know.
Is that real?
I'm trying to hang on.
Jamie?
Do I look okay?
You look good.
All right.
Then moving gun like you're losing
weight.
Yeah.
No,
you have to do something.
We all that training.
You do and you're doing that much
training.
That's crazy.
That's really awesome.
I really love it.
That's beautiful.
Yeah.
They tried to do one strength training
at the House on that style with club.
If you want to come here,
man.
Well I'll work you out.
We'll work out together.
I was thinking about calling you.
Maybe you can give me a kickbox and less
than this and you know what else we
could do?
We could do like a circuit,
a circuit training because I have that,
a eco air bike,
that echo bike I've never done.
That's phenomenal.
So we could do a rose the ACO bike and I
got a versa climber and I like to do,
um,
in a,
do those Tabata sequences.
So it's like you go hard for 20 seconds
and then you rest for 10 seconds and
then you go hard for 20 seconds and the
restaurant and you do like eight rounds
of those.
It's fucking intense.
And then you jump on over to the row
machine.
The machines,
there's another one similar number.
It's like 30,
30,
hard,
30 off,
something like that.
And then you go to the versa climber and
you plug in some.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm 52.
I'm almost 51.
I'll be 51 in August to August.
It's really interesting what I've
learned and what I read about 50,
I show a picture of Carol.
Okay.
About a year ago when he was 46 years
old,
when he was doing,
while she finishes what Jesus only said,
well,
go to that picture.
Archie bunker was stopped or when he
started out,
it was a picture and it was 46 and I was
like,
there has to be a better way.
Let me see that.
I saw holy Shit,
you know,
this is what America is crazy.
What did you look like at 46 and 47?
And you were like,
look at that dude.
He looked like,
well maybe that was like in the later
years.
There's a funny thing,
right?
The lovable racist.
He was like the last of like he
represented a real guide that might've
had racist views that were kind of funny
and he was just some way in deering
because he was such a good actor and it
was such a good character.
So well written and his relationship
with his wife and his kids and with
meathead.
I mean the whole thing was,
it was a brilliant show.
Well,
it's such a well crafted show.
Sammy Davis kissed him on the lips when
fucking Puerto Ricans do wallet.
Rican guy comes over there talking.
He looks at his wife from Puerto Rico
was alice,
don't just stand there or something.
And she goes,
I don't know what he likes.
And he goes,
I don't know,
a Puerto Rican his drink.
And he looks at him,
the guy smiling.
I'm like,
he looks something like Puerto Rican
drink.
He goes,
I don't know.
How about some pineapple juice?
You know what I'm saying?
The guy looks at it,
you get thrown off the Ed today,
but it wasn't that.
It wasn't hateful.
It was queens.
Racism.
Well first of all,
pineapple juice is delicious.
And why is it racist that a dude from an
island would want some pineapple juice?
I would think that.
Would you be culturally sensitive to
like introduce that possibility,
that something that you do have a
tradition of drinking?
Because if I said to you,
listen,
I'm leaving him,
I'm going to try and make a fireworks.
Somebody heard me say it to you right
now.
Tomorrow we'd be good fucking.
Yeah,
we would have a problem.
I would have a problem where everybody
knows at 20 years ago,
right now,
I'd be heading to Chinatown in New York
City.
Get the fuck on the matter of fireworks.
One hundred and 44 bottle rockets.
A couple of Roman candles.
You know what's the most stupid man is
that the food is somehow racist.
Like there's.
There's food that's racist food.
Like if you talked about black people
and also talked about delicious fried
chicken or delicious Orange Soda or
grape soda would be grape soda right
now.
Orange Soda.
So it white people.
Yeah.
Orange Soda is a white people thing,
right?
White Trash,
Orange Soda?
No.
Is that.
Not that I'm anti Orange Soda,
but I'm saying like those foods like
watermelon and particular,
if you talk about a black person and you
talk about watermelon,
that's a racist term.
Even though watermelon is delicious.
It's fucking weird.
Like what the hell could be wrong about
watermelon if you don't like the taste
of watermelon.
If it's a hot summer day and somebody
busts open a cooler and gives you a
slice of watermelon,
how fucking pumped are you?
How could watermelon ever be negative?
That don't make any sense.
To me,
it makes zero sense and the only way it
makes sense that fried chicken can be
negative to you is if you're a Vegan or
a vegetarian and you don't want to eat a
chicken.
That's the only way it makes sense that
that would be a negative because
otherwise like fried chicken,
it's fucking delicious.
Who doesn't like fried chicken?
If you eat meat,
fried chicken is something you smell it.
You.
Oh,
if someone's really good at making it
and they got a nice flaky lay on the
outside,
you bite into that juicy,
perfectly cooked chicken fried chicken
in Tennessee,
Tennessee,
a little fried chicken,
Jesus Christ.
There's places that know how to do some
fried chicken.
God,
how could that be bad?
How could that ever be racist?
I.
That doesn't make any sense.
We got to let that go.
I'm going to tell you a racist but not
really like sad.
That went to the park with my daughter.
I'm sitting there.
This was sitting on Sunday with the
beanie and his wife with glasses was
Sherman oaks and had a $10 bills to
pocket that wanted to work my fucking
pickpocketing skills.
I want to say still pickpocket
motherfucker.
I even have my daughter bumper into his
leg and stuff.
You can't pick pocketed,
jude.
Doug,
you can't do it.
You know,
when I was a kid,
that was my first fucking dream to
pickpocket movie with our boy that and
Michael Cyrusone who are the.
The first pickpocket movie is called
Harry in your pocket with a boy in your
flint.
Flint,
James Coburn.
Teams.
Colburn was in a pickpocket.
Nobody knows about it.
Hit the American's greatest secret and
they would work airports and shit like
that every pocket.
So I hunted down my mom.
I used to hear them talk about this
Cuban pickpocket guy and Cuba Cuban,
the 15.
Oh yeah.
Tremendous.
You do with him.
You did something with him,
right?
Oh yeah.
I did two things with him.
I did American gun with him and I did a
list with him.
All this is up.
You could find out that's online.
Somebody just posted in the wallet,
I forgot about our list.
That's one of those shows that I forgot
about,
but I watched him and I asked this guy
out.
He become a pickpocket.
I bumped into him at a Cuban joint.
There was a rumor going around that he
was a good Cuba pickpocket and Cuban.
He goes,
you've got to get a dummy and put bells
on the pockets.
That's where I went and I don't know how
I got it.
A little dummy and I put bells on and
fucking years.
I tried to be a pick pocket,
but I have begun hands.
Yeah,
you got to have those slender,
slender,
her fingers.
Little tells on fucking pockets and you
bump into them and shit.
I'm very light footed that I am.
I was a good burger because I can tip
toe.
You know what I'm saying?
Like that's where my ears are.
Tip Toeing on the dummy.
So trying to take the wallet from the
dummy.
I could just never fucking dummy.
It's great that you're doing so many
different things though.
It's really cool to hear your role.
Then doing some more time and the
rolling has really improved because at
first you can't roll.
I,
I dropped the weight because I figured
for every five pounds I'd be a little
bit more cardio.
Get.
Plus I got the mouthpiece.
I spoke to them yesterday again.
He liked that thing.
Huh?
I really believe in it.
I use it while you're working out or do
you usually what?
I walk.
You're walking.
When I walk,
I take a walk in the morning,
20 slash 30 minutes explaining to people
what it is,
the boss,
the boss route and mouthpieces on Amazon
that says webpage.
I saw it because he was on joe talking
about it.
I was having such a struggle with my
breathing.
I was having such a struggle,
but it was just common sense.
Number one,
I smoked cigarettes for 20 years.
Number two,
I smoked for 40 years,
but all those are just excuses.
The number one thing was the weight.
Every fucking second is some smart guys
at hand.
Some bastard.
He's such a handsome motherfucker.
He's a great guy too.
He's one of the best people I know.
Some guys say to me,
great guy,
a great brown belt,
told me that whenever he rose,
he could feel the difference when he's
10 pounds every.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Whenever I go to my mother's and I come
back that first week,
it's brutal really.
And I go,
so if I'm walking around with three or
nine trying to be fucking Eddie,
it's not gonna work.
So I just started shopping the way I
went back to weight.
I
walked in there at three,
10,
have a bunch of different rules now,
like what you can eat,
what you can eat.
I'm going to tell you something.
You can eat as many eggs as you will see
you in the face and the face will look
in the face and tell you because you
know,
you and I always had this conversation.
If you're heavy and you don't go to
weight watchers because you're a fucking
loser.
Whoa,
that's it.
It's that easy.
It's that easy because I'm an idiot.
I'm going to enjoy it.
I'm a fucking idiot.
And pop hip hop.
Come on.
That's my guy.
So,
so you,
uh,
put everything you eat into this app,
to the APP.
Oh Nice.
Okay.
Let me show you what I was.
I got dinner,
snacks total.
And then you,
uh,
you counted on by points.
Is that what they do is they do it
themselves.
You know how many points you get in a
day?
Thirty nine.
Now let's say Joey,
would you eat that?
Give me a can of coffee right there.
Give me that one problem.
You don't think?
Okay,
we don't know.
So you scan that and then it'll tell you
how many.
I don't think that has many calories.
Does coffee,
plain coffee of calories?
Not really.
Maybe a couple,
but not really.
When you get the fucking milkshake
coffees for breakfast and he and the
fucking flat white,
the flat white don't cut you.
All right.
This isn't in that.
You go like this,
boom.
And then you got this Joe Rogan.
You're ready.
You press this over here and you press
this here and you press this here and
they give you points for whatever you
do.
Walk Circuit Training.
Then you have custom.
So I press Brazilian Jujitsu.
Lets you go to an hour class.
How much do you really fuck them?
Roll.
Fifteen minutes.
People don't know what class you're
doing.
Technique.
He teaches you how to do the drill and
he tells you a joke.
So you press and 15 done and then you
press the intensity.
Will you breathed on?
Adam?
I just bet seven points.
You leave this in your phone,
in your pocket.
You put this in your pocket and fucking
guess what happens?
It counts the steps.
When I went to Disneyland,
that burge dirty one fucking points.
So it's all the executive for breakfast.
So for breakfast I go to John's and I
got to see that role.
Even if I give myself full fucking
points for the row,
five points,
six points for the role.
I put two eggs on that motherfucking,
which is 14 grams of protein.
I put a thin slice of humans.
Boys had an American cheese and some
frank's hot sauce on that motherfucker.
I ain't gonna.
Talk to me.
So you essentially can eat anything you
want as long as you know what the points
are.
I get a certain amount of points.
Fish,
I cut out fish you for days,
so I'll leave here and go to fucking
Sushi Dan,
and I'll get the crunchy albacore,
which is.
I can't wait for Rogan to visit me.
It sliced albacore covered with
Jalapenos,
onion and garlic cloves.
It's possible.
Let me ask you this.
Is it possible that you could eat just
all eggs all day and it has zero point,
zero point?
Really eggs all day,
all day.
That sounds crazy.
Fish all day.
Sea Bass,
all you could eat salmon and sea bass
all day.
Chicken breast,
no skin,
no skin all motherfucking day.
All Day.
Chicken breasts,
not chicken cutlets.
Mom made with Italian breadcrumbs.
No,
no,
no.
That's fried grilled chicken breast with
red crushed peppers and a baked potato.
Five points for the baked potato.
Oh,
so you want to tell me again how
listening.
It's not a journey.
It's not a fucking race.
She before.
It's only healthy.
Lose like a pound,
pound and a half a week.
Is that what it is?
That's what it really.
They say anything after that,
you go into that loser show where they
lost all that weight at one shot and
then that's why all these diets and
stuff that you have to do on something
that you're going to do forever.
I've always liked this.
I lost 100 pounds with this.
Yeah,
and then I gained 40 and now I lost
another 30.
That's awesome.
And it hasn't been killing me like I
don't miss nothing.
You know,
when I learned I didn't know this,
I will go get an outside.
He bought American thinks announcer.
Ebola was great.
Let me explain something to you.
Eating a banana and putting them banana.
The blend is two different things.
I did not know that when that was making
one of those,
because I switched.
I have on it proteins,
which I use the vanilla or the
chocolate,
the Mexican chocolate,
and then I had this other one that's a
polio type protein.
It's coconut milk and I put a use that
one in one day.
So let me put a bland in this
motherfucker just to see it.
I'm like,
damn,
this is delicious.
I'm onto something.
I gained weight that week.
I didn't know what it was.
I'm the banana.
When you blend the banana,
it's eight points,
but when you eat a banana,
it's gods,
but it's for you because when you eat
fruit and when you drink fruit,
it's two different things.
That's why walgreens fat people,
when you see him going,
I don't eat breakfast.
I drink a smoothie.
You're killing yourself.
You were killing yourself every time you
puree fruit because when you eat fruit,
the sativa,
it's alive.
It's saliva's.
God forbid the saliva in your mouth
breaks the fruit down and digestive the
sugar a different way.
When you bypass that enzyme in your
mouth,
that's when you get 300 pounds like
uncle joey.
So when you drink fruit,
I don't care if they tell you,
oh,
it's frozen fruit.
You lose some of the sugar.
That's bullshit.
Once you fucking blend that fruit,
you dead because it goes right into your
sister.
Go out as the assistant,
all the fiber and was like,
why?
Why?
You're not supposed to learn that shit
any other way other than the way that
comes when you eat it.
You can go to that fucking little
Mexican stand with the umbrellas.
You ever see those guys?
The cartel could delivery.
Is that what that is?
Yeah.
That's when the cartel drops that money.
Shake him down and I got three that guys
over there cutting fruit with a machete.
Go ahead.
I dare you to go up.
When you see a cod,
tell umbrella that that's a cartel money
that,
that they got tons of money in those
days.
They just confuse people.
They even got them across the street
from one another.
Well that starbucks.
Don't you think they're just poor people
and trying to make some money?
Not really.
You're not going to get me apples.
You've got to sell the fucking pay rent
in this 10 days and times.
Nobody stands out there.
Look at those.
Mexicans don't even use SPF.
They're out there raw with no fucking
umbrella out there.
They look darker than dark.
They get dark.
Were you thinking you?
You know,
but you got to pay me to standing out
there on fucking thing.
This weather a lot.
They got like $200 a day,
$300 a day.
Not because they're cutting the apples
up because the guy comes with a Poncho
and takes what's underneath them and
takes it straight to Mexico on
Thursdays.
Nobody sees nothing that every time you
eat that fruit and sprinkled with
cocaine.
He told me that fruit.
Well now watch the energy.
You get like that box of roaring for be
poor farmers because that's how nice
people are using.
For me,
I'm a criminal.
I see people for what it is.
I see things for what is.
I'm trying to sell the leader or rehab
because I got a friend that's got to
rehab.
You go down there,
so send lead to him because he could
make money.
There's a rehab,
there's a bunch of rehabs or Florida you
go to and they get your insurance and
they bang your insurance for 60 and then
they give you a cut back at 30.
I totally let me send you down into my
buddy's.
Give me 10 percent.
I get three grid,
get acupuncture to give you a few
massages or do you give a fuck the rehab
business?
Imagine who would be in terms of his
marijuana consumption.
Imagine where he would be if it wasn't
for you,
like terrorists.
That guy when you first started having
him on your show when you guys first
started doing smoke pot,
maybe three times in college,
a couple months in.
He's done superhero doses of edibles.
Couple months.
I mean like little by little,
little by little bit.
When you would sneak him in on him and
you would take away at 2:50
and pointed a $500.
What I would do,
wrap it,
I get this is Joey Diaz,
Costar and the Church of what's
happening now is completely asleep at
the wheel.
He's on the show and his eyes are almost
totally closed,
is barely a slip.
They just dazed.
Who's the guest?
Who is that?
It's right in Bosnia.
A kid that I told on this podcast,
he can't take him though high.
What is the name of this video?
Jamie Lee space.
Outer Space.
Look at him.
Go.
He's guy.
I would get these.
Okay.
I would go in the afternoons and I would
get a one 80 and I would rip the cover
off the one 80 and I would take a 67
slash 60 milligram woman.
I'd eat that one.
It was like two in the afternoon.
They don't do nothing to me.
I'll eat like a 60 and I'd take the one
80 and pulling the 60 rapper.
Oh No.
And then I bring it to him,
put it on the table and in front of them
I go here and then open it up for him
and he wouldn't see it.
It was half open the reading,
give them the 60,
but it was like last night I gave him an
expired where they had a little bit of
mold on it.
He's going to be a good comment a bro.
Look at eleanor.
Eleanor sat there for 15 years,
shut her mouth and watched.
There's a really special gift to that.
What do you think was funny in it?
Whether you agree with her.
I give her the balls.
A lot of people don't like just sitting
there and watching.
There's a lot of people that do though,
you know,
there's a lot of people that work in and
around comedy clubs that probably want
to do it.
They just don't know how to get started,
you know,
they just don't have it in them to get
the ball rolling.
It's hard.
It's hard to.
Hard to try something new.
He keeps thinking about when's the right
time to do it.
Is it now?
Maybe.
Should I wait a week,
you know,
you know what?
I want to lose 10 pounds and then I'm
going to try it.
And you get all these things in your
head.
How long did it take you?
Seriously?
Honest,
honest,
honest engine.
Well,
my birthday was August 11th and uh,
when I turned 21 was August 11th of 2019
88 rather.
So I got on stage August 27th.
So from my birthday too,
when I got on stage,
it was just a few days.
It was just terrified.
Terrified.
I was trying to check it out.
I'm Jonathan Katz was the emcee and um,
I was maybe going to get up.
It was one of those things were signed
up for the list,
you know,
you get,
I think it was five minutes and there's
a bunch of people that are going to do
five minutes and Jonathan Katz who was
already an established standup comedian,
really funny guy,
and he was the host and he's like,
um,
he came up to me,
he said,
let me check in a half an hour in to see
if I can get your.
Cause sometimes people wouldn't show up.
And so a half an hour in,
I'm,
I'm thinking I'm just going to check it
out.
I'm just going to bail.
I'm just gonna tell him forget about it.
And when I'm thinking this in my head,
I walked up to him and he's,
I got you in jail.
So,
uh,
you'll be going up right here and you'll
have five minutes.
Good luck.
And I said,
well,
all right,
thank.
Thanks man.
Okay,
so I was ready to push out,
dude.
I was totally ready to push you out and
I was so nervous.
The first time I went on stage,
I was fucking terrified.
I couldn't believe it was the name of
the place.
Stitches,
stitches,
comedy club.
August 27,
19,
88.
I was terrified.
Terrified.
I couldn't believe I was scared.
I didn't.
It didn't make any sense to me.
I didn't think I was going to be scared.
I thought maybe it'd be like a little
nervous,
like I'd never performed before.
So this idea of doing and it was like,
well,
you know,
I've,
I've taught taekwondo classes in front
of people before I can talk in front of
people.
And then I thought about the idea to
stand up in front of people,
so don't fuck it took me.
It's crazy.
It took me a year to think about it
because then it snowed.
I couldn't go to work because we can't
roof in Colorado.
Right.
Should I read to the punchline with Tom
Hanks and sally fields?
Angel Salazar.
Damon Wayans,
a bunch of people in that movie.
I watched punchline and that pissed me
the fuck off.
That was it.
I went into the yellow pages.
I found comedy clubs.
I called them and comedy works offered a
Tuesday night open mic.
How do I get on?
You have to call in and they'll give you
three minutes.
Okay,
so for two months I called him nothing.
And then one night there like Joe Diaz
and I called him back that night I got
sick.
I got the float was like I'm not going
out of their.
Wow.
And then I was roofing,
roofing,
Mr Madan jobs.
I'm going to different jobs and dropping
off material.
I'd like to cruise working and I went to
one crew when they go,
hey man,
we're stuck here,
this job.
Can you get us the morning break?
And I go,
yeah,
I'll go over there.
And I went over to this little diner
right off the fucking dirty,
whatever that I 77,
25.
Which one?
But when the Denver it was like our
industrial area trucks everywhere.
I don't remember what the number of that
road is.
A road there,
but there was a place around the corner.
Jamie had the best fucking Green Chili.
You add your fucking life and when you
pulled him over fucking scrambled eggs,
you dick would get fucking fuck.
Two to a t is,
are you kidding me?
That goes fucking to walk over there.
I sit down and you know,
there's always a paper in front of you
ever go to a diner or something.
There's always a paper.
Somebody read and I sit down,
I give the waitress.
I'm sitting in,
I look over and I went like this just on
a,
you know,
you just go like that to the middle.
And when I opened it it said,
do you want to be a standup comic?
Whoa.
And it was an article on Roseanne became
a standup comic and now because of
Denver,
she had just blown up like Rosanna had
just blown up.
It was maybe march of 91.
Rosanna had just blown up.
Denver was a hotbed Jack.
Everybody was drinking the water or be
wanting to see what Rosanne was doing.
So it had a big thing about Roseanne and
it had all these open mic spot and it
had the classes that you could take and
there was a class in boulder for $33,
three Sundays in a row at the University
of Colorado.
Part of the continuing education,
the guy that taught it,
his name is jeff harms and I went the
first Sunday that okay with the second
Sunday did okay.
In the third Sunday I performed on the
way out.
He took me aside and he goes,
I don't know how serious you are about
this,
but you're onto something.
If you want to do it,
let me know.
And I left there going,
I want to sell coke.
Fucking crack jokes,
cracked fucking jokes,
pickpocket or fucking fucking come up
with birds and shit.
I swear to God.
I'm like,
are you fucking crazy?
I don't know if I can be a comedian.
And then about a month later I saw an ad
in the paper for Dorman for comedy
clubs.
I called it up and they said,
come up on the way there.
I called Jeff.
He gave me his number because he said,
when we got on stage,
just me,
I'll put you up somewhere and I go,
there's a job for a doorman at wit's
end.
Do you think I could get it?
And he goes to the alcohol.
The Guy Right now,
you got it.
Just dragged them,
fill out the APP,
you tell them you're friends with me and
it made me a doorman slash sound guy in
the bar back quit.
So I was the door guy,
sound guy in the bar back and after
about six months I had two jobs.
I hated going home.
I had a marriage that was just fucking
just like the one that we all talk about
when you cannot go home,
it's not your home anymore.
I would basically leave at six,
come home at five,
take a shower,
eat whatever fucking crap she cooked,
give the baby a kiss and I get in my
truck and go back to Westminster.
It was a club away from the comedy
works.
It was in Westminster,
but it wasn't.
It didn't get the best people in the
world.
You know what I'm saying?
You have to lose people in there.
People will poach bands and shit like
that.
So I still have.
And then in the middle of all that,
it took me two months to get a spot from
Wendy and then I went down at Nicholson
army,
one of the original owners.
Mr Wendy with comedy comedy,
comedy works in Denver.
He was one of the original owners,
but when he had Nicholson,
he told me to keep coming back,
but I knew when I walked off that stage,
that life as I knew it has ad ended.
How so?
Whatever I thought life was at that
point.
I had gone out the window like I.
Saturday was fucked up for me because
Saturday I was supposed to be somewhere
this week,
but I couldn't go.
I had to go to my friend's mother's 80th
birthday party and why it was important.
It was in Philly.
It was away from philly.
She's in an old folks home.
They're the second family that took me
in when my mom died,
but they took me in a crucial spot.
Gel,
you're throwing me out.
I'm 17 and I know where to go.
I couldn't go to my stepfather,
so I had an aunt in New York and I can
live with and I had a godmother in
Harlem and I didn't want to live with
both on the job.
Like I wasn't mad.
I just mentioned to a friend one day we
were out snorting coke drinking and I
told him,
I know what I'm saying,
they gonna throw me out of the data and
he wasn't even good friends with me and
about a week later I saw him at school.
I think it was a man.
I talked to my father.
You could move in with us.
That was whose birthday?
It was on Saturday,
so when I got off the phone with her I
was thinking about how important they
were to me,
but I still remember being 17 and
sitting on that hill on 86th and county
blvd.
Thinking about how I had nowhere to go
bro.
Like This was my only shot.
Like I had nowhere to go nowhere.
There wasn't like a homeless shelter.
I didn't know where the fuck to go.
I probably had $10 in my pocket and then
the younger brother ran up,
down.
When he goes dog,
they're waIting for you to come to eat
the dinner.
I'm over there.
I had never met the parents.
How lucky am I?
I never met the parents.
That's pretty lucky and I walked in and
they had like six kids and there wasn't
like what I was used to living.
They had nowhere to conditioning.
The parents were blue collar and they
took me in.
I made me a part of that home,
never asked me for rent,
wasn't the fucking best house on the
bLock,
but to this day I'm tight with all the
four brothers and sisters.
It's like,
well,
we're all one big family,
but then kind of fucking lucky like I'm
not even talking about being thankful
for the comedy bridge.
Just a personal bridge over like I was a
killer and in and at that point I had
lost all faith in humanity.
Like I was done.
like I wasn't a catholic no more.
I was just waiting to kill somebody.
That's it.
That's all I was waiting,
man.
It's such a weird,
like I'm not even worried about the
comedy bridge.
No more was the personaL bridge where I
grew the most,
you know,
I don't even know how we got In this
conversation.
This week is killing me.
It's good weed.
They're going to kill the good weed now.
Right.
Is that what's happening?
How does this work?
How does it.
No,
no,
no.
I still got some guys.
Yeah,
I'm sure you do legally,
but illegally for.
It'll still be available for medicinal
people that have.
we've got to get a card.
Recreational.
It's going to be to renew that card.
Son.
I go,
I got to redo that car.
I don't want any of your bullshit weed.
I don'T want to eat your fucking water
down.
We'd.
What are they going to do?
They've got to water it down.
18 percent.
Something like that,
but never fear.
But here's the thing.
Isn't that strong?
Look at this.
we've got a da went to.
Oh wow.
Will you think you're dealing with his
joy?
Bananas.
We got state,
federal.
We've got them coming from all over.
You know what I'm saying?
Damn tea.
Fuck you.
Just in case,
just in case with tom cruise,
the american made.
I was looking up the medicinal rules in
Ohio recently.
You can't grow your own there if you
have a card.
Yeah,
they're sneaky with that shit,
right?
Yeah.
Hopefully people eventually voted that
out,
but you had to get it in there first.
That's the only way It would have
passed.
They have everything wired up,
but it's a.
It's a victory because it's gonna be
very difficult to make it illegal.
Now that it's legal,
it's going to be very difficult to go
backwards.
So then you have to figure out like why
do these companies have a monopoly on
making it as if it's legal,
why can't you make it yourself?
Aren't tomatoes legal?
I can grow tomatoes.
Can I.
You could even probably grow,
like,
do you need a tax stamp or something to
grow tobacco?
How does that work?
Maybe to sell it.
I don't know.
If you want it to grow your own tobacco,
would you be able to do that?
Like if you said,
I want to make my own fucking pipes and
fill them with my own tobacco,
I want to make my own cigars.
Could you do that?
It's a possible for personal use.
That's crazy.
So if you could do that federally and
then they're saying you can't in Ohio,
you can't grow your own weed.
That's so stupid.
That's so dumb.
Like you even know what you're doing.
Know I don't know dick about it.
I wouldn't do it,
but you should be able to.
If it's legal,
of course you should be able to grow it.
That's it's a fucking plant.
Not blow it.
Where can you not grow?
In Ohio,
if you have a card,
here's the worry.
The worry is that you wouldn't charge
taxes.
You would keep the money.
You wouldn't be accurate.
You just do it with cash.
You do cash transactions.
That's the worry,
but that would be a tax worry more that.
Right?
Is that what it is,
what they're saying tobacco to?
Yeah.
You can grow as much as you want.
You just can't sell it.
Oh,
okay.
But you did not even allowed to grow
their own for personal use when it comes
to marijuana,
so it's more restrictive than tobacco,
which is,
hi larry,
this silly fucks.
That's so dumb.
Does that make any sense to you?
Listen,
we have some wacky laws that we let
sneak through,
like why would you let other people
decide that different people in this
group can't grow a plant that's legal
now,
get the fuck outta here.
That's dumb.
That's a dumb rule.
They can't some edibles over a hundred.
No weed.
That's loose.
So if I come into your store and I go,
what do you got?
You can open up the container and show
me the butter.
Let me smell it.
They all have to be sealed and stuff.
There's just a lot of silly rules.
I don't know which one to stay.
Don't.
I'm very happy I found this bag of
expired.
Fucking sheba.
Choose to listen.
You know me?
I make it work.
Are they diminished in any way?
No,
no,
no.
A couple of her.
A little bit of mold.
Donald,
would you just take them old glove?
I put a little brown nail polish on it
and nobody knows about that.
Like Who gives a fuck?
A little mold.
never killed.
Nobody motel people.
Penicillin.
Penicillin came from some old,
didn't it?
Something like that.
It's so crazy how you see your kids.
You see it with your kids.
I took my kid to science camp and when I
came from Cuba,
I had a lot of problems medically here
when I came to this country and one of
them was the allergies.
The allergies were completely different
than what I was used to.
A different country.
Their fucking mind boggling.
So my allergies.
Have you ever hit me?
Made that noise?
You ever do that?
Because I don't.
I can't scratch the back of my throat
like normal people.
Normal people do that noise.
So you all sealed up up there.
The first week of camp I saw my daughter
to do shit.
I felt so bad for her.
She would try to scratch her nose and I
would see her get frustrated.
Joe rogan just scratching and scratching
and scratching and now it's three weeks
in the summer camp.
She don't scratch.
No.
How come?
Because you build up your immune system.
It's so weird how you see it in front of
you.
Now you see,
I see.
I saw in front of me like I went right
to my wife and I go,
let me tell you something,
you want to take it to the fucking
doctor and get a fucking tonsils out
because that's the shit that started
with me at that age when I came from
Cuba right away I was in the hospital on
a weekly level dog weekly between the
tonsils and the fucking allergies and
asthma and the asthma,
but my mother didn't pay attention to
the.
But that's why I don't have it today.
Like I might have bits and pieces,
but I don't have it.
mercy's got it.
My daughter's got it.
They got to do the inhaler and the whole
thing as most fucking rough.
It's rough.
That's rough.
I've seen people have asthma attacks and
you can hear the wheezing and you have
no fucking idea.
So I have to work it from a different
angle.
What can,
what can they do?
LIke if someone doesn't have an inhaler
and they have an asthma attack,
a strategy or technique referenced and
mother fucking party.
Oh no.
So you have to be like,
I was having a party right there.
Have a great tIme.
I got an estimate.
Their inhaler opens up your lungs,
children,
my wife has the machine,
the machine,
the machine that blows some powder in
there with a thing.
And then there's a regular machine that
my wife has.
And then she has dna.
Uh,
you know,
my wife and her doctor been working on
different things.
She's healthy kids.
Healthy is fuck.
She runs,
she swims jujitsu.
That ballet,
you know,
it's,
it's four days a week.
We don't stop at that fucking house.
You know,
you just,
you see it,
you know people.
I love these people that
say,
oh,
let's meet at 3:30.
You tell your mother ministry 33,
30 is my day really starts because I'm
saying I'm writing jokes at eight that.
Because I want that because that's what
I got.
Yeah,
that's what I got.
That's what I got because I got this,
that,
this,
and at 3:00
from monday to friday this different
activity.
Sometimes you do three at a time,
bro.
We gonna write from jujitsu right to the
pool.
When she jumps in,
you think we could do me then go for 45
minutes.
Fuck you,
jack.
You gotta.
See it.
It's unbelievable.
People like,
nah,
let's meet.
Fuck you.
I got ballet.
I got a thousand fucking activities
during the week.
Kids are little energy machine and if
you don't burn that energy then you deal
with it and from seven to nine when you
fucking trying to do your own shit and
trying to get it together,
they're just constantly ready to go.
THey're ready to go.
A couple of weeks ago she took her to
the fucking zoo.
Six hour walk around la zoo.
I get home at four.
He's like,
what's the story?
We're going to the park.
I looked at my wife like park,
took it to the park,
two hours on the monkey bars and then
another hour at the fucking yogurt place
jumpIng up and down to music and Michael
Jackson and drawing pictures.
Really?
It's crazy being a fucking debt
especially because then I'll know I
kidnap some bio.
She's.
She has no idea.
I'm a savage,
so she thinks I'm on the up and up,
like when we go to church and shit,
she's like,
daddy,
look at jesus as well.
Nothing turns people more on the up and
up.
then being a father,
it really does.
Yeah.
It changes who you are.
You're responsible for these people now
and you just do.
You have to think of things differently.
You have to make sure that you provide.
Do you have To make sure that they're
taken care of?
You've got to give them love.
It's like,
ooh,
it's an intense world and you feel more
vulnerable and it's just the whole world
around you opens up and you also have
more empathy.
I have way more empathy for people now
because I'm becoming.
You know,
as you're raising children,
you're seeIng how they develop and then
you considering how other people have
been mistreated and how things have gone
terribly wrong.
They've been abused and beaten and
fucked up and then left and terrible
situations,
and you realize that so much of what
happens with people with even terrible
behavior comes from other terrible
behavior like they didn't get a chance
to stop the cycle and there are a lot of
people that we consider like really bad
people,
violent people,
people that do terrible things that we
don't even realize that so many of them
are product of violence,
like they're a product of someone doing
it to them like they've.
They've almost,
they're trying to get back at the world
for all the horrible shit that's been
done to them and there was no one there
to put a stop to it.
There was no one there to save them.
There was no one there to protect them
and this is what we're seeing.
When we see fucked up people,
we always just think of it as fucked up
people would.
That fucked up person is the product of
some terrible things that have happened
to them.
Almost universally.
Almost every angry,
fucked up person has come from a place
where something has gone really wrong
against them.
You don't,
you're not angry and fucked up.
If everything's awesome,
if every day just get an ice cream,
getting your dick sucked and driving a
ferrari and watching awesome movies like
you know,
it's,
you,
there's a,
there's an anger that some people have
violent criminals in particular that
comes from someone doing that to them.
I had a job.
I know you had that anger from 1979.
You had that shit when I met you.
I had that angle.
But no,
the met you.
I've seen it.
I've seen it with people.
Let me explain some to wanted to attack
people.
Anger was very,
uh alright.
First of all,
under control.
I was always a happy kid and,
but not really because I was always
confused about the death of my father.
So had always had a little certain
unhappiness.
Yeah.
But I always had the catholic faith.
I was really raised catholic and I
always believed he was in the habit that
he was in that box from my mom did the
things,
so at ease the pain a little bit.
Then my mother's death was just fucking
horrifying and that broke the central
nervous system belief system that broke
your belief in the world.
how can there be a god that takes a
mother away from a chIld when you're 16
and you wrap that around?
Your head does not a good result.
It's not going to be a good result.
So how I lashed out with,
by robin you,
that was the only weapon I had world was
to rob you.
Joe rogan,
fucktard,
me.
The studio will get robbed and lit on
fucking fire and joe knew was me.
And what the fuck was he going to do?
I'm,
we combine the fuck you going to do it?
Call the cops.
I'm going to answer the phone next time.
Don't fuck with me.
You know,
next time when I tell you to give me
that grandma coke and I'll pay you on
friday,
you'll give it to me,
right?
Because that's what it was.
IT was simple shit like that,
right?
Like joe,
give me 100 bucks or $100 bucks.
Okay,
now rob,
your fucking house should have given him
100 bucks.
You know,
I was lashing out at the fucking world
number two.
The other issue I had is I lost a child.
I lost the job.
I was not ready for that child at all.
I love that little girl with all my
heart,
but I was not ready for her at all.
My intentions are good,
but the result was not going to be well.
I was noT ready and because I lost that
child and I'm a no contact with that
child,
it makes me a better father than I am
today.
This is never going to happen to me
again.
You understand me?
I see.
I see the,
we see daughters of comics,
we've seen daughters of comments and
sons of comics and if fucking lost,
you know,
I don't want my daughter to be fucking
lost and that stupidity in that world,
you know,
you have to be that job.
We have to be there.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm trying to be there as much as I can
be engaged.
You have to be engaged.
Were your parents engaged as much as
you're engaged?
In my mind,
but I didn't want a different world.
Yes,
it's a different world,
but my parents were very openminded
what?
What my parents gave to me that was
really important was they.
They are like the most nonjudgmental,
non racist,
non homophobic people ever.
They don't judge about anything.
They were hippies.
You know?
When my mom met my stepdad,
he had crazy long hair and he had it
like all are all too.
I was like almost in high school.
It was when he cut,
I was so happy when he caught it.
I was like,
people were.
It was like back then dudes grew their
hair long.
They were hippies,
like legit hippies.
But because of that I was raised around
like no racism,
no homophobic.
We had a no homophobic thoughts in our
house.
We never.
That never came up.
We lIved in san francisco from the time
I was seven until I was 11.
We lived on a series gate and the one
thing that did disturb me though,
once I was walking with my stepdad,
some dude whistle that adam was like,
I knew the dudes were gay,
but there's a thing about when a dude is
hitting on your straight stepdad and
you're like,
oh my goodness,
this is ridiculous.
Like guys are growth.
It makes you realize,
doesn't even really make you realize
what it would like to be a chicken.
That same exact grew up completely
different.
Not in my home,
not my home,
but the surrounding.
You know,
when I would walk down the corner,
mr tina and we'll go pick a rule where
you going,
you know,
there was a kid and I still talk to him
on facebook.
His name was louis and in this he's
dominican cho,
he's dominican,
he's dominican.
They didn't give a fuck.
They called him louie the nigga
constantly,
louis the negativity.
The guys,
he's dominican.
If they gave a fuck,
they didn't give a fuck.
They didn't give a fuck.
So funny.
You know,
they didn't give a fuck a pro or just
different than.
It's a different world.
We're talking about right.
I remember there was a kid that is today
gay.
I still talk to him.
He's my brother.
As a matter of fact,
he's one of my brothers.
I gotta be honest with you.
He lives in miami.
He's got hiv.
I mean,
listen,
if you didn't know he was gay when he
was 12,
there's something wrong with you.
Ms dot tina used to call him.
He was lightened the slippers looking.
Look at jimmy,
he's white and this slip is,
you know,
and you had to sit there and take it.
It was whatever.
It should be.
Okay.
for a little jimmy lightness slippers.
Everybody should just let him be who he
was.
He had a dog named tramp that wouldn't
have his dog ever.
He lived outside tramp skin.
Like when you pet the fucking thing was
the hardest.
It was like a,
like with those brushes you scrub the
metal brush,
like you've lived outside tramp.
But he followed him everywhere.
He was beautiful.
I love dogs,
but you're very lucky because I did the
best.
I grew up in an environment standing
with you when my man on the corner,
we see a trans gender person crossed
mystery,
like look at the shape of this fucking
guy.
As simple as that is as a judgment,
but that judgment,
but it was more of a sense of humor.
You know,
before we were looking at a picture of a
of archie bunker,
America understood it because he knew
where he was coming from.
He wasn't saying nothing malicious.
It was a world where he came from and
the idea was that he was reluctantly
open to occasionally taking new
information.
Today,
every guy's sItting at home fucking
looking at a window,
pick him,
waiting to fuck him to get me.
Dude,
there's a thousand men at home waiting
right now to get me fucking to everyday
a new guy get called out for something
like that.
What's this going to be like in five
years?
Nobody's going to be able to even ask
for fucking piece,
right?
Nobody's going to go,
hey,
let me give you a little stab.
Let me give you a little buckaloo wish.
I think
going to come a time and then I don't
think it's going to be very long within
10 years where we're going to be able to
read each other's minds.
I think we're going to be able to
communicate in a different way and I
think it's just going to be step one
into some sort of a technological world
where we all read each other's minds.
We can connect together and some almost
like telepathic web way.
The way you use a.
This is obviously just an idea,
but I think that if technology continues
to give us closer and closer access to
people,
we're gonna lose all boundaries between
what a person is and you're going to
know everything about everyone's past
and everyone's going to know everything
about yours and it's going to be like
some unlimited library of the mind.
You can.
You can travel through anyone's mind and
read anyone's thoughts and as hundred
years goes by and the technology gets
better and a thousand years go by,
we're going to integrate.
We're gonna fIgure out a way whether
it's in our grandchildren's lifetimes or
their grandchildren's lifetimes.
And I think that cultural shifts and
things that are happening in the news
and people waking up to things that they
think are horrible and people trying to
correct the misdeeds of the past.
All of that is us waking up in the
middle of our culture and trying to
figure out what's right,
figuring out what's the healthy way to
move forward,
figure balance this thing out.
Slow down.
What are we doing?
We're waking up as grown adults trying
to figure out our system and there's
some injustices.
Those injustices have to be corrected or
at least recognized.
We have to understand what's the
difference between normal male female
interaction and what sexual harassment.
What when is it when someone doesn't
want you to do it,
when does it become a crime and you
don't want your daughter to ever
experienced that and I don't want
anybody that's a woman to experience
real sexual harassment.
It's the worst fucking thing that could
probably ever happen to you because you
can't do anything physically about it
other than rape or being beaten up or
murdered too creepy place to be in.
I've had guys hit on me before.
Have you ever had a guy hit on you
before?
We use.
Where is this going?
I was like 13.
I didn't know what to do.
I ran out of the car and it was my fault
for getting in the fucking car.
I also acknowledged it never fucking
happened again and I would go to gay
this when I was a kid,
like we thought it was a joke to go to a
fucking porn theater on a sunday.
Here we got to a point on a sunday,
like we're stupid friends and going to
the bathroom and there's always a guy
that gets next to you in the store when
you go pick and it looks at your dick
and he smiles.
Come on guys.
I bumped into a lot of creep.
You been out here.
first of all,
I tell you what bothers me about the
current situation now.
Went off that this fucking place.
He has always been a fucking haven for
sexual harassment.
This fucking neighbor down the corridor
here in hollywood is with sexual
harassment.
Got invented.
Did you ever see,
um,
all the stuff about fatty arbuckle?
I heard pieces about fattier but,
but I don't need to know about fatty.
I know about a chick named Marilyn
Monroe that they passed around,
so they killed the,
I know about a game,
a liberace.
We used to suck his dick and fucking
clean you out and then send you out the
fucking cold and worse get plastic
surgery.
So you looked like you look like him,
but is one of the most intense things a
person's ever made a person to.
Let me tell you something.
Let me tell you something else too.
That's while we welcome the elephants in
the room.
The fucking we hang out was known for
comedy.
Fucking hell of them.
Convicted a lot of years.
The comedy store,
a lot of dick sucker went down to
fucking calm you store.
I don't know how long harvey weinstein
been around,
but there's a song by the eagles in 1980
that was released on the fucking long
run than last.
Now it's called the king of hollywood on
the way home.
Put it on.
listen to it in the car.
You're going to crash your car,
called the king of fucking hollywood and
you're going to go,
hold on.
Fuck.
Were they talking about?
I have to assume I'm going to.
It just breaks it down.
It would be a shame to see all that
talent go to waste.
You know?
What are you willing to sacrifice would
really be just nice.
Oh,
you got.
Look at this shit down here beside me.
Honey.
Let's have a little heart to heart.
That's the fucking lyrics to this song.
Well,
Kenya,
hollywood,
1980.
Nobody knew.
Now look at me and tell me,
darlene,
how badly do you want this part?
Yeah.
What's listened to put men in positions
of power and hiring women like that and
that,
that crazy position of what you're
trying to cast something and you've got
a hundred people that want it so bad and
you're.
You know,
you're some creepy dudes.
Some people actually think this would
change their life if I came to you right
now,
Joe rogan.
You're fucking delivering papers in
boston.
You'd have to show her podcast.
There's all you to do is look my fucking
bowl.
Oh my goodness.
Just swap one time,
but I want you to.
Do I want you to do that thing at the
end.
like a dice?
Yeah.
Like would you do it?
How much think,
how much do I get and how long do I have
to suck them for?
Did he says it's going to be over pretty
quick.
This is the career changer.
If I may do this,
do that.
Right?
That's who they're talking about.
Oh,
the king of hollywood.
It was clark gable a um,
was he a gay man?
It was based off a book.
Apparently all this stuff that was in
there,
but he was,
he alleged to be a gay man.
Is this.
But there was also a book released in
hollywood in 1997 or eight called.
You'll never work in this town again.
Oh.
So those lyrics were about clark gable.
Yo,
I'm sorry.
I thought it was something.
Yeah.
But then there was a book released in
1997 or eight in this hollywood called.
You'll never work in this town again.
And there was about a chick who
described her sexual relationships with
a bunch of people in town and she
described it was fucking don henley,
the drummer from the eagles,
the guy that sings and he would get
hooked us to come up to the house,
wouldn't even talk to them,
but why them up,
turn around,
don't even look at me,
don't even make fucking eye contact on
me.
They understand me.
Bend over.
So he would sIt on the couch,
we road bond with his dick out snorting
coke and they would all be in front of a
fireplace.
Breadth over,
where'd you hear this?
Because this book will never work in
this town again.
Jesus christ.
And he would fuck it.
You never eat lunch at this time again.
Oh,
you never eat lunch.
And he would take the thing,
do a line of coke,
get up and walk up to one of them,
spread them,
putting them in their ass a little bit.
Firstly,
puppet twice,
and then go,
I'll be back in five minutes.
and then he would go sit down,
put his feet up,
do another line.
And he would do that for eight hours,
just get up,
fuck one for five minutes and sit back
then before he'd come.
So he would never crack a nut and he
would just keep going to keep a heart on
a live fucking.
Who the fuck knows?
Listen,
you know,
it's like they all through the harvey
under the bus.
But these animaLs had been doing this,
says jesus loves chicago.
Since jesus miss chicago,
this one I read that article about the
cuban superman that they brand them with
sleeping,
with what they blatantly talked about In
our article was exactly what we're
seeing today.
only behind closed doors that Cuba had
become a haven for sex.
Where you couLd go see a fucking go get
fucked.
They passed a rule thIs week in Mexico
that a girl could get fucked up.
she's 12 years old.
You really need that room.
Really?
That's the rule.
You need something that you Could be the
age.
12 years old is an act of,
and this is Mexico,
Mexico,
james,
12 years,
12 fucking years old when he just as a
woman,
12 years old.
That's insane.
It's
scary it.
Oh jeez,
you fucking believe that.
oh my god,
look at this.
The federal law established at the age
of 12 as the minimum age of consent,
while the age at which there are no
restrictions for consensual sexual
activities is 18 sex with someone 12 to
18 is not illegal per se,
but can still be open to prosecution
under certain circumstances.
He really.
What does that mean?
So It's,
it's age 12 is the age of minimum age of
consent,
but the age in which there are no
restrictions for consensual sex is 18.
So the idea is that sex between someone
who's 12 and 18,
it's not illegal,
but they might be able to lock you up if
you do something super creepy.
That is nuts,
man.
You imagine if there was some person
that just only went after 12 years,
is that the United States or Mexico?
It's Mexico,
so that's why people would fly down.
Actually I typed it in Mexico,
but this is an article on wikipedia
about aging consent in north America.
Why federal law?
So I'll find out,
wait a minute,
that what I just read was about north
America.
How is that real?
I just saw north America too,
and that's why I asked her states.
Right?
I'm sorry.
Not in north America.
United states of America.
Right?
North americas,
Canada to.
That is,
that is uh,
that is not possible thing.
How is it?
Is that really possible?
The 12 can be the age of consent
anywhere.
What are you talking about?
That's crazy.
18,
right?
That's the federal law of Mexico.
Mexico.
He scared the shit out of me.
Jamie.
Here in America.
It's not yet.
Yes.
That's what the article is about.
North America.
Age of consent in north America.
And there is states here where it's
lower than like there's a couple.
I believe it's 14.
Dude.
Is that real?
It might've changed it.
Okay.
So 12 for the ones.
The 12 are the ones that were in white,
which is,
that's in Mexico right here.
Yeah.
Okay.
There are spots and all the way up the
coast.
Right?
You have,
that's still Mexico done here.
Yeah.
That side.
But that,
that whole thing is 12 years old.
Is the age of consent a blue is all 16.
who?
That's a lot of states.
16.
Yeah.
That's kind of crazy.
A lot of fucking us dates.
That's crazy.
14.
18 central.
Excuse me.
was this say central America slash 14 to
18 and central America.
Interesting.
That's that age of consent thing is
bananas.
Go back to that little map again please.
That is weird to look at.
I would have thought there would be way
less of those 16.
Look how many sixteens there are and
what are the darker ones?
Can you scroll all the way down so we
could see the whole scale?
So 17.
Is that around and then wow.
Tax green is 18.
So like Florida,
California is less greens in there are
blues more.
The age of consent is 16.
Is this current,
is that possible?
This is not current.
It seems not.
Alaska 16 to.
I assumed it was all
Florida was like eight.
You know Florida could be like seven,
six and a half.
You never know that.
I'm fucking that crazy place.
That is a fucking crazy place.
That's where white people go to boogie.
An interesting.
I just found out about,
it was a time you go down and just buy
pills over the counter or something.
Go pain.
Doctors.
Pain medication.
Yeah.
Like I just read this shit recently
that,
that law got abolished something.
That's why so many people left Florida.
There were people moving to Florida in
droves.
Just whose pain?
Doctors in droves.
I didn't know about this shit.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a great documentary that we've
talked about many times called the
oxycontin express and they sort of
documented that whole route from Ohio
and Kentucky and all the way down
through georgIa.
All the people that would go into
Florida just to get pain pills,
all you had to do is just get into
Florida and you'd get a doctor and say
you hurt your back and they would have a
pharmacy right next to the doctor's
office and all the pharmacy had his pain
pills.
So you go there,
you tell the doctor,
you're heard.
The doctors is great here.
Here's some fucking serious hardcore
drugs that can kill you.
Don't take more of these die.
They're super powerful opiates.
But since I wrote the wrote it on this
piece of paper,
you can go buy it.
So you go next door and you're buying,
you're buying the hardest of the
hardcore.
You're buying hillbilly heroin,
you're buying oxycontin and you're going
deep.
Now.
I've never done that shit.
I did morphine when I got my knee
operated on.
They gave me that little pump thing and
you could press it and press it and
present and you want to get more
morphine.
I don't,
I have no idea what oxycotton like,
but that morphine
felt wonderful.
It feels like the cognitive not feel
good.
What does it feel like?
I one time and that was good enough for
me.
Some people must like it.
Everybody likes different shit.
You know?
I like blow black,
like met.
What did,
what did oxy do for you?
Like why is it not good?
I took a little tiny piece,
like I'm always a fan of something that
might put me to sleep.
View like this caN put you to sleep.
You know what?
I'll give it a fucking shot.
I like sleep.
You try to go to sleep on oxycontin?
Yeah,
I didn't know.
I go,
what?
He goes,
you might pass out or he gave me a 16th.
It was,
there was nothing,
there was nothing that I popped it and I
just felt like my blood pressure
dropped.
Like I couldn't even do anything.
So I went to sleep and I just know never
to take that shit again.
There's certain shit I've taken that I
just knew that I was never gonna that
just wasn't going to work for me.
Damn,
you know,
heroin has done effect too for a little
while.
I,
it takes you somewhere and if you don't
put the brakes on it and shit,
then your gun on that thing.
I don't even know how to describe It,
but I don't mind that feeling,
you know,
the cocaine feeling you'd like in the
beginning then we're go,
you don't like it and it gets worse and
worse and worse,
but by that time you were addicted to
it.
You know what I'm saying?
Matt?
I never understood that shit.
Wanting to be up for four days that that
just seems.
And you will be up for two fucking days
thinking you tie it,
but let me go lay down and I can't
sleep.
I'm sweating on dose to sweat.
So pills I've always had.
I like a little fucking sleeping pill or
something,
but they can't because of this sleep
apnea.
Yeah,
they're too dangerous.
Right.
I can take the anxiety medication.
That'll help me.
Sometimes I'll pop a few.
We're just stuck there like as a plan.
But like one point five told them to
nothing.
To nobody.
Point five.
Do find that we'd let you go to sleep at
night.
Don't do deck.
You ever seen me at night smoking weed
because the initial effect was in the
daytime.
I like that morning.
Hi.
Why do you like that?
Because that's the one that gets the
whole.
That's the one that lets me email text.
We didn't think that the all by 9:00
or by 9:00,
get It either way.
Call six,
put the coffee on the computer,
feed the cat,
pablo it,
she the pablo escobar pablo.
Open your eyes and bed.
Roll over and take a joint and smoke it.
That's no brainer.
You got to let your body wake up that
low.
Whether that's the quickest way was that
fucking thing.
Yeah.
Let me take a hit.
I love that little blunt.
That fucking gino from speed.
we'd the some of the best fucking jamie
picked this one up.
This is.
This is a place down the street.
what's it called?
The blunt or something?
I don't know.
Hollywood's dedicated.
Blind.
Yeah.
Waken up and pulling the pablo people
dedicated.
Yeah,
it's medicine man.
okay,
but you wake up and give your body some
chance to like.
I remember smoking cigarettes in the
morning.
You don'T know what,
what damage is to your body until you
wake up in the morning.
Take six steps,
sit down and pull the cigarette out and
whited.
There is no worse damage.
A human being could do that.
Body.
Forget heroin.
Forget eaten a few avocados for getting
a burger.
king.
Whopper.
Get up at six in the morning.
Give yourself three minutes and by the
cigarette you body does not recovered
from that and you don't know how bad it
is to you.
Stop doing it.
That damage.
So I look at it the same day we reef,
I let my body wake up a little bit,
but at a drink water.
Let the bodies heat could drink a glass
of water with ice.
Let my body wake up,
get the stomach going,
drink a little coffee and then bang out
some referral.
It's a different day.
And you'd like to work out in the
morning to write.
I'm 55.
I can't come to your house at 8:00
at night,
but I can't.
I'm not going to roll with you.
Is six in the morning either.
Most attacks happened before.
One time.
Do that?
Yeah.
How come?
I don't know.
I didn't write the book and check it
out.
MosT heart attacks happened before
fucking 12:00.
So you don't want to be.
I know you don't want enjoy in your
site.
Control at six in the morning either.
I'm good at nine to kickbox tend to
kickbox 11,
12.
The jujitsu eyes.
You got to wake everything up.
That's the whole deal.
Heart attacks are more common in the
morning.
Says fox news five to six times more
likely to occur in the morning hours
between one and 5:00
AM,
and studies have shown that morning
heart attacks tend to be more severe and
those that happened later in the day too
long or too short of an interval can
result in abnormal heart rhythms called
arrhythmias.
As a matter of fact,
I had stuff giving mother stabbed in the
mornings.
You're worried about heart attacks
because that was my more.
I love pushing in the wake them up.
Whoa.
When you kick mama with that leg in the
moRning,
you know what I'm saying?
You can be a little wife a tap in the
morning.
She pops her head up and then they,
they already know they get up,
they pee,
they drIve the monkey good.
They come back,
they could you eat that fucking monkey
and then you start giving them a stab.
Him like a soldier and that stabbing
dog.
I wouldn't have to get up and start
breathing heavy.
And then I thought about that.
That fucking gangster tells me to
testify that time in court and he bent
over to tie his shoes and he had a heart
attack and the guy ended up doing a
fucking jail and we had to talk about
that in a second,
but we will cover the heart attack.
I take a baby aspirin before I go.
I drink something from gnc to get me
going a little bit in the mornings.
I still take my protein powder I live
by,
but I do take us up before I go to the
gym and I do drink something while I'm
at the gym to calm me down a little bit.
What do you drink?
something from gnc.
Gnc.
I don't know.
Hm?
No names,
no names.
performance levels.
I always pop a shroom tech again,
I don't pop to showroom texts.
I pop one and I started with a half a
capsule because it was finally my heart
was beaten too much to take a year.
You got to watch the ticket.
That's interesting.
You know,
listen,
god gives you a certain amount of text
to your heart.
I did cook that.
That fucked up the whole clock.
That fucked up the speedometer.
You get sand in your dials.
The dials I got fucked up the dominance
and I got to strengthened a little bit
in that strengthens it,
but there's a lot of shit you could do
without thinking like a marathon or
something.
I watch my fingers numbness.
I go,
I get a finger up my ass as much as I
could from the doctor I use.
I overuse insurance dollars.
Like I'm going friday for a blood test
wide join because I'm in the mood.
You gotta switch up every couple months.
You know what I'm saying?
You gotta switcH it up like Keith
Richards.
He's still alive because he switched it
that women don't die of heart attacks.
why?
Because they believe every month will.
He only answers that.
don't take the fucking word.
I'm just relaxed.
You don't want to be enjoying your
conversation.
You're just smoking so much weed.
You getting paranoid?
No.
I love take it down and getting deeper
and deeper into the whole like what's
the matter?
Nothing doesn't matter at all.
It's great to see you.
what's going on with normal shit now I'm
coming tonight.
You go down there tonight.
Tonight.
I've been taking a few days off after
the netflix.
Yeah.
Nice.
I want them to fall in love again with
it.
I want it to a good to take time off.
It's really weird how you live and you
learn and you still for dumb shit.
You know the only person I should listen
to him when it comes to comedy is you.
And I don't see you enough that I don't
talk to you enough about that.
I got to get more planes with you
because when I tried I watched the john
and special fell in love with his joke
writing and stuff.
It's very funny guy.
Really nice guy.
That's fucking great.
Fucking special,
you know?
But every once in a wHile.
I'm sorry I'm saying this word.
I always think I get the white moment
and I'm not a white.
The reason
why you liked me and the people like ms
dot [inaudible].
You doN't know what's going to come out
of my mouth when I become a writer.
That's what I'm not a comedian,
normal.
When I go home and start writing stupid
fucking jokes and you laugh at them.
I'm not joe.
He is no more.
That's not what joey diaz as opposed to
do you know what I'm supposed to do.
But this shit that's happened now scares
the shit out of me.
So now I gotta go up there.
You pay 25 bucks to see me.
I ain't got a luck thing and leaving my
soul up there.
I take that shit seriously now,
but I'm starting to take a little bit
too seriously.
ThIs shit you see now in what way?
That the people coming to the shows,
people coming to the shows to see you.
They need and they want to do you to see
you do well.
So I go up there with this plan material
that I work on heart that I believe in
that bullshit because I'm a lot
friendlier when I go up there and I just
fucking yell and scream and go off the
cuff and go crazy and my eyeballs jarden
red.
But no,
I want to be john waYne because he makes
me fucking laugh and he's what in your
mind that you comic is everybody's got
their own way of doing it?
No,
and that's what I realize.
I'm going back to being a fucking
lunatic.
I'm going back to midnight spots next
week.
I'm going back to midnight spots going
back to kylie,
kylie,
going back to cali,
going back to those spots.
I know they're late,
but they're the only ones that keep you.
If you're going to play it,
if you listen for me to be in uniform,
that's the only way I could do it.
That 10:15
following you.
That ain't fun no more.
We gotta be back there late like we used
to go on four hours of sleep for two or
three weeks and then you gotta walk me
over and buy me a fucking pink that
sandwich like in the old days.
Why don't you like the 10,
15 spots?
because they put me in that position.
I'm sick of fucking been in that fucking
john malaney position.
I'm not john malaney.
I'm going,
what do you mean?
But I like your dad to see me because
something's going to come out of my
mouth.
That's going to be funny,
funny coming out of my fucking mouth and
listen,
I love you,
but you're.
That's crazy.
Talk you.
What you do is your way of doing it.
It's great at 10.
It's great.
At eight.
You could do it.
Three in the afternoon show would be
amazing.
They stare at me at the original room.
I'm going back to midnight.
I'm taking the kennison spots again
three nights a week because that can
handle it.
That means I get home at 1:32.
You're going to do the late spots.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
The reason why I do this early shit is
because I'm trying to be normal.
I read that book,
your podcast.
Like I said,
okay,
now I like this.
Hold on a second.
So you're going to close out the store
and do like an hour long set.
No,
no.
15,
12 slash 12 slash 15.
Oh god.
So you're not going to do like the don
burris situation.
That's what listening to joey,
at least for the moment.
I've just saying you got,
but you can if you're closing out the
show,
right?
You could go along.
I don't want to close out the show.
One of the more.
I don't want to be out.
I'm scared of go out at night.
So it's not a thought.
You were saying you want to do the
kinison spot?
Midnight.
Midnight spot when he would do that
spot.
Oh,
I thought he was always the last guy.
I thought it was the.
I mean that's what they always say about
brody,
but he does the kinison spot and I
thought it was the midnight run.
Let's call it the poem on the spot.
Okay.
Well just you want to do a late night
spot?
I think they do a lot better.
I don't have to go to.
This will be out for sure.
Yeah.
You ready for me to.
It's time for me to be.
I'm a fucking degenerate.
I should say that fellow degenerates.
Yeah.
I'm to block in the morning.
Nobody's saying one.
Do I say one?
I said 12.
One in the morning.
12,
12:00.
You know you're getting up at one
though.
12 slash realistic?
No.
12,
10.
You might get disturbed professionals at
the store.
They're pretty professional,
professional.
There's no more fucking people coming in
and bumping you.
Well,
that still happens a little bit,
but not too much.
They don't.
No one jumps on and does an hour and a
half like the old days.
I miss.
I missed that 12:00
thought of mind.
The top tWelve for me in the old days
was.
I swear to god joe.
They've already heard everything.
Yeah.
If they.
If I think they really want to hear
these three jokes,
but pocket.
I got think of it and it taught me how
to write really good.
What do you.
What has changed recently?
Like the one of the things a lot of
people have been saying with a
especially the me too,
movement,
that people are more cautious about st
controversial jokes now.
do you feel that you feel like energy in
the air being different?
Do you feel like,
I know you won't get mad at me.
I feel the eneRgy is different,
but guess what jay,
but it don't apply to me.
It don't apply to me,
doesn't apply to me,
and it's never going to apply to me.
Okay.
I understand me shooting your special on
your network.
You don't want me to use certain words.
This parts and I get that.
This is a business.
This is business as I got mouths to
feed,
but when I'm at the comedy store,
when I'm at the improv,
when I'm at the laugh factory,
when I'm in flappers,
when I'm at the ha,
when I'm at the New York gotham,
you got to let it fly.
I'm old.
Let it fly,
let it fly.
Okay.
And I'm sorry.
No,
no,
no.
He.
Sorry.
Just so you know,
you know what I put on yesterday.
Would you put on.
That's what I put on the studio
yesterday and this is it.
This is it because it's time.
We're not taking it no more.
I'm not taking it no more.
I put on an album,
but again,
I'm very sorry if I offend somebody.
I didn't name it.
He did.
So take your fucking problem up with.
The name of the album is bicentennial
nigga by James Richard.
Richard pryor.
I put it on,
I listened to it twice and I did it.
had a ball and cried.
I got fucking.
I've got the,
the periscope listening to richard.
Okay.
I got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
And I've liStened to lenny bruce live
from carnegie hall in the last couple of
weeks.
I don't know when the last time you
listened to that because we can't
because of our,
uh,
we guys like you and I can't.
Definitely not jamie.
And definitely if you're under 30 you
can't because of the cost.
This is how slow cultural references and
how slow it is,
but It's a lesson I listened to that and
I'm going home gets wrong.
Listen to tonight what I'm staying in
tonight.
Listen to the one when he meets the wine
on to dRacula.
Oh,
I think you'd see the.
Is it something I said or the niggas
crazy.
Both of those albums.
A masterpieces.
and that's how he wanted us to do it.
That was how we have to do it.
He didn't give a fuck what the fuck was
said.
If a company wants to pay you hbo or cbs
and joey,
can we talk to him in the corner?
We can't have that jump because we got a
complaint about that.
I'm an adult.
I can't sell.
You know,
listened to bill hicks is dead.
No,
I don't feel too good myself.
Okay.
All right.
Let's cut the fucking shit.
Okay.
we do this for profit.
at the end of the fucking day.
We're feeding our families.
Right?
So.
But there's also a way you do it.
And there's also the way you do it for
profit.
you know,
when I watched the richard pryor thing
and I know he went into a hollywood bowl
and they were doing the thing for gays
and he went up there and win against the
gays.
I got it.
It's something I would do.
I don't know.
I don't know,
but it's who was supposed to be in a way
as a comedian.
What's supposed to be the social column
of society in a way,
in some way.
So now you want to take that away from
me.
You want to take the way.
I can't say I grew up on the word
retarded.
I grew up on the word faggot.
I grew up on the word.
I grew up on a lot of words that people
don't accept today and I'm very sorry
that you don't accept them,
but it's too late for me to change my
game right now.
Yeah,
I'll try my hardest.
I try my hardest.
I'm still gonna.
Say tranny from time to time.
I know it offends,
but when you're a comic.
Listen man,
the first seven minutes of any news is
about what's going on in the world in
the next 10 minutes is bad.
I never talked about politics.
To top it off.
I'm a felon,
so I need to talk about pounds.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
well,
there's just things I'm not going to
talk about.
Kicking an abortion child.
Remember for a long time every comic was
kicking a born at freedom.
That's not my style.
I'm up there to talk about,
you know,
for the board of.
Yeah,
you go to comedy shows and there's
always trying to be shocked at wants to
be shocking.
I'm not going to be shocked.
I'm 15 and I'm here to tell you hoW I
see it.
You want to see it.
This is how I see it.
If I offend you,
I didn't offend you to before.
In the beginning of the shoW,
I said something very offensive until
term,
but in my reality was really,
you won't fire crackers.
You buy it from a chinese dude now then
charlie,
why is that racist?
Because that's racist,
but as a society,
how is it racist,
factual chinese people out of fireworks?
Weird.
There's weird ones that we all let fly.
Like black dudes with big dicks.
No one's complaining about that.
Right?
Do you ever hear that you assume black
dude as a big deck because anybody
combined?
Probably They're looking to.
Now that might be like maybe I'm the
first one to get called out on it.
That's racist.
To think that black dudes have big
decks.
Is it is if it's positive,
is it pot is like a positive attribute.
Racist.
Like if you said asian people are better
at math,
people would say that's racist.
How is it racist?
If they're really good at something,
like if they have more talent or skill
or more accomplishments hasn't racist
but isn't that racial if it's good,
right.
Like jews accepted.
If you tell ari that more european jews,
one nobel science prizes,
he's like,
of course we're smarter.
Is it,
is it racist to talk about how many jEws
are so fucking smart?
Like why is that?
Why they say god damn smart.
even think about how many german and
european jews were like fucking serious
geniuses.
It's crazy trend.
Like what happened over there.
Callum waS trying to explain it to me
once,
but their values and their education and
the experiences and what led to just
google the numbers of european jews that
have won nobel science prizes.
It's kinda like it's eyeopening.
You know how many Guinea from New Jersey
and zero.
Zero guineas from New Jersey when
insights.
Right.
None of my relatives went in science
projects in this up a couple of weeks
ago.
It was hard to look at.
Oh,
is it?
Yeah.
What did european jews that have won the
nobel science prize?
Try that.
I don't know.
I don't even know what these numbers.
I'm talking about my ass.
I know that it's.
I've definitely heard it discussed that
there was a giant number.
What are you doing over there,
joe?
He doesn't text me and let me know what
body I need to be at.
Oh,
4th of July baby.
This is our.
Our country's birthday is a time that we
should cherish.
I think we should play the national
anthem mayBe later.
We got it.
Okay.
But you got to play the national anthem
real quick.
They have on this morning by my house.
I loved it.
I fucking love it.
So how was your experience during your
netflix special?
Everything was good.
Great.
Netflix.
I'd take my hats off to them.
Everything was great.
It was my fuck up.
I let it get into my head too much.
I listen to too many people because I
forgot the number one thing.
Just be felony that shit.
Be yourself.
It doesn't matter how many shows did you
film to?
First of all,
I think was a disaster.
The second one,
I redeemed myself a little bit.
We'll put something together and we'll
save something.
So now I'm working really hard.
I'm like,
no,
I'm going back to my old roots.
How I want to do my stand up again.
It's hard when you only have two shows.
Going to shows.
Is todd more bullshit?
No more.
I Listened to.
This guy has nothing to do with me.
I'm a stand up comic.
That's what I signed up for.
What do I got left?
I'm 55,
but I go back to doing.
Stand up another 10 years maybe.
I got to stop now.
You're going to shut me down now.
This is where we get started
is where we get started.
We got to.
We got daughters.
When do you think about.
Do you think about ever stopping doing
standup?
Because I do.
Occasionally I think about it and then I
take a flight back with dice from New
York and I look at dyson before I
approach them.
I sit down,
I look at them from 10 feet away for 10
minutes and I think to myself,
is this what I want to be doing at that
age?
And I think about what,
what would we be doing?
What would you really want to be a run
your wife and your daughters every
fucking weekend for every fucking week.
You're already used to leave in one
weekend at least already used to it.
There's going to be a casino.
SomeboDies going to pAy you once a month
and leave the house with two if you
would you be happy with your act if
you're only going out once a month.
Like if you weren't going up and
practice and going out once a month
could be awful.
But I'm saying yOu still hosting the
pizza place on Wednesday nights and you
still,
let's pretend you move to columbus,
Ohio to columbus,
Ohio was so high io and you work the
funny bone once a year,
right?
And you do your little pizza,
open mic somewhere down the corner a
couple of nights a week.
They look at you as the older guy.
They all came up looking into comedy,
Watching it,
you know,
they listened to you.
You know,
when I started in economy,
I started,
the guy's name was george mccalvi and
george mccalvi was a really special guy,
joe joe,
because he had been on the tonight show
with,
with the whatever as a comic I sustained
and that's the fucking epitome for one
of us.
Whether he became a richard pryor or
not.
He was on,
what's his name?
Come on fucking help me.
I have no idea.
Tonight show Johnny Carson.
Carson did stand up and johnny put them
on the couch,
you know,
to derail the Georgia mccalvi was the
real deal.
When george was 70,
I'll never forget.
He called me one night.
He's like,
hey,
what are you doing kid?
I go home to sydney.
He goes,
drive to Colorado springs and get
onstage.
Open up me.
I go,
I can't get on that stage because of
famous manager.
That was that.
That's that.
That club at the time [inaudible]
wouldn't let you get on stage unless you
took a comedy class with 35 bucks.
Oh,
that was a scam.
Fuck,
I'll waive it.
So he threw me out on stage and this old
guy,
me that old guy had no career
basically.
He did the local places.
He owned two clubs and he worked a
couple clubs at,
hired him still he died on the road or
whatever.
My point being that he helped me a lot
as an old guy.
Like I looked at him and at first my
first opinion of him was this whole
losing.
No,
it wasn't a no loser.
He hadn't been doing it for 30 years.
He committed to this and no matter what
his turnout was or whatever,
he was still a comedy.
He died a comic.
I talked to him maybe two years until he
died and I had lost contact with them.
Well george carlin died on the road.
You know,
my greatest of all time.
I don't want to die on the road.
And then I know you don't want to die on
the road.
No,
but I can't.
For years I thought I wouldn't be doing
this at 50.
Guess what?
I'm 55 and I'm still doing it.
This is what's important.
You're still letting it swing.
You're still having fun and doing a lot
of crazy shit that gets you in a lot of
trouble today.
This is what I brought up with.
We were talking about the,
you know,
in air quotes me to era.
People are going after people today for
good or for bad and to still have a
wild,
controversial act in this politically.
Hold on one second.
What are we going after?
Me to people for?
For me,
taking him to back grabbing it.
Teddy's grabbing your pusher for you.
Sucking my dick for a movie role or for
something like that.
All those things really don't exist in
my life,
right?
I have a wife and I have a child.
The only exist them right away.
If you want to come at me for sucking my
dick and night in 2002,
we were both doing blow be my guest,
be my guest,
but I want to see footage.
I can be.
I'm sorry and take it and just.
You know what I'm saying?
There's a lot of people out there.
They're going to get me to look at this
other guy.
For years he was known as a heroin
addict,
never got accused of sexual misconduct
and some chicks that cima less than when
he was 11 years old and now he's like,
you need that,
and the chicks on drugs.
She's doing the press conference while
she's on drugs.
What's his name rather than one?
The guy that was in heat that the neuro
put them in a rehaB himself and then he
married heidi fleiss for awhile.
Who was with tom?
That guy's been a junkie for 2000 years.
All of a sudden.
Why can't I remember his last sizemore
size?
Mom have some girl comes up when she had
26.
Yeah,
he molested me on a movie set when I was
11.
That's great and dandy dog.
But you can't ruin some of these life
now,
but what do you think is happening?
This is my question,
like why are.
Why are people accepting these,
these situations like the chris hardwick
situation or why is everybody instantly
thinking that the guy's guilty?
No one giving him the benefit of the
doubt.
No court,
no justice court.
There's no nothing and in some some
cases,
like the worst case was garrison
keillor,
garrison keillor's,
the host of the lake,
woebegone chronicles like this radio
show on pbs think it is,
is that what it is?
He apparently hugged a woman and his
hand went down her back.
This is,
this is the depiction,
and he apologized to her and he sent her
an email.
She said,
don't Worry about it.
It's no big deal.
It was nothing.
And then they continued,
I believe,
to correspond and we're friends again
and then this is all this stuff start
happening with al franken.
And then he had this complaint brought
up by this woman.
She reintroduced it and said that a long
time ago,
he put his hand on my back and they
canceled the show.
They took his name off of it and they
did it like really quickly and it's one
of those things where you just go,
okay,
I really like the guy in one moment in
time touches someone's back.
I don't know if it was creepy or not.
Let's assume it was a terrible error and
it was creepy.
I don't think it was.
I don't know.
I'm not saying I know,
but that's it.
Just touching someone's back and you.
That is a hysterical reaction.
That is hysteria.
That's almost the definition of
hysteria.
If you're not talking about evil person
talking about a person who touched
someone's back,
like we got to be real careful with what
you destroy a person's whole life with.
So on the one side you have the worst
case scenario,
which is like a bill cosby who's
drugging people and raping people.
So worst case scenario for these
powerful elite type people that are
getting these women into their web and
pretend he's another one,
which they will all live on it and
everybody knew about it was written into
his contract.
It was sexual harassment clauses were in
his contract,
right?
It wasn't that.
It was known for.
Make sure we're correct.
We really bothers me about harvey.
I'm going tell it what bothers me about
harvey,
what we got to die.
There is a lot of people that have to be
indicted and this is one of my feeling
right now.
This would be,
this should be a rico act.
This is the rico act.
Agents manages oprah,
eddie,
because everYbody knew everybody,
but here's a question.
How much do they know in 2005?
Everybody knew Joe Diaz was a kofi.
that's a dIfferent thing though to stay.
Let's pretend the same thing.
Okay,
but let's call Joe Davis is a coke feet.
It's 2007.
Joe is comes to a party house.
There's two cell phones missing.
Okay.
Let me.
Let me say this though.
Do you think that it's possible that his
behavior was shielded from some of the
people that he interacted with,
like hillary clinton or oprah or bill
clinton or whoever that was,
that they.
Some high profile people that he
interacted with.
Is it possible that they didn't know?
Is it possible that they just thought he
was a pussy hounD or do you think they
all knew he was a pussy hound and they
heard little chitter chatter,
but it's okay.
It's okay.
Would just let him show
me.
That's number one.
Number two,
jamie,
you ready for this?
Oh jesus.
Okay.
I see joe,
uh,
whatever.
Not now,
but Five years ago.
I see joel and the first thing I had to
go with joe,
before you leave,
don't forget I got a.
What was that story would be about,
about benson.
Henderson is choke about a joke that
somebody said the store going to place I
went to and some chick took me in the
back of suck my dick on the car and then
she stuck a finger in my ass and that's
what we talked about.
So if that's what we talked about,
you're going to look me in the fucking
face like a man that you are in,
the men that you've been around and told
me harvey weinstein never turned to brad
or his other bodies and listen to.
Remind me to tell you the story about
that dirty fucking battle
for sure.
Okay.
Then for sure.
But that was after that.
That's been admitted.
I think they've had conversations.
Oh my god.
If you don't think that the wig,
ben affleck and the other guy and I'm
not offended.
No,
but I'm Just talking about boys.
What boys?
Right.
And I have boys.
What?
You won't say that,
jamie,
you'll say to me because you're going
watch blind date.
No,
I've never watched a movie blind date,
blind crackers going off in a movie
named blind date with Bruce Willis.
Oh,
I remember that movie.
Kim bassinger,
how larry's came asked me just steals
the show when she walks in,
the japanese lady and she was like,
you know,
you're entitled to 50 percent of your
husband's assets in California.
And the chinese woman kept saying me,
no,
speak english.
Speak english.
I was like,
you don't even tell 50 percent as she
opens up The door.
Fifty percent,
50 percent.
That movie is a great word,
but this is seen in the opening of that
movie.
Both of those aCtors are around where
the guy comes up to him.
He goes,
you're not gonna believe what happened
last night.
And Bruce Willis goes,
hey,
we go one of these fucking sex stories
Again.
And he goes,
so,
um,
that's bongos.
I hope when I walk out with some lady,
pulls up with a limo and I say,
I've never been a little limo.
She goes,
we'll get in.
And we were riding down sunset hard
times in the summer and the next thing
you know,
she's sucking my dick.
She's got leotards on eating,
harass,
and he's telling the story.
And Bruce Willis,
listen,
when it goes,
no,
why does this always happen to you?
This is some other bullshit.
He goes,
and he goes,
ms dot.
He starts whIpping out polaroids.
That I've always known one of those guys
in my life.
of course,
we've all known one guy in my life.
That was the difference between that guy
and what harvey.
Why don't believe stuff?
Yeah,
I know that.
But I also believe that harvey,
I was telling people
he probably was because listen,
everybody was telling him.
Was he telling him that he was holding
people down?
What do they usually tell him?
What was he telling?
He was raping people ass.
No,
not at all.
Do you think that he did?
Well,
you only want to use a piece of ass.
She's a piece of ass.
You've got to see her suck a dick.
She'll do anything she is an animal
with.
That's what we do as men were
braggadocio.
So there was like a community of that
were actors and actresses.
I think he had four or five guys that
knew what he was doing.
I want you to remember being 27 and
having floor your boys that would come
back every monday with a different story
to karate school.
Yeah.
Eight harassed.
I fucked her on fire.
Whatever the fuck is that yOu do.
he told somebody.
Somebody knew about all these stories.
Some agents knew somebody because for
100 of them that said no and whatever.
That had to be.
Twenty five.
He was playing the percentages,
joe.
Well,
definitely.
In fact,
a lot of people said Yes.
They blamed that one girl.
They had the one girl that did rounders.
They accused her.
Yeah.
Heard that.
That played matt damon's girlfriend.
She was.
She went from being an extra and fucking
a donnie brasco to being the guest star.
Opposite fucking.
Yeah.
If you want to.
Donnie brasco,
she's what's his name?
Sonny black's girlfriend,
you know,
made lines.
She has in that movie
zero,
zero smart move.
And then a year later she's a fucking
guest opposite.
So there's a bunch of them that said yes
to you,
but do you fault the girl for doing
that?
Have a girl decides to harvey weinstein
on her own freewill and we come here
with a dream and there's two ways to
enhance that dream.
Because I always knew that I wasn't good
looking man.
I always knew I was fat.
Now I always knew I was already lit art.
Listening to what I always knew that I
was funny.
So I always worked on being funny.
I didn't think somebody was on let me
suck their dick or eat their pussy to be
a star.
So that was never in my mind.
But think about people who.
How many people have you met with sell
that?
So when this town,
how many people have come and gone in
front of you?
The reason why our friendship is still
intact,
it's because you know more and worker,
you know,
always hard worker.
You respect hard work.
how many times did you pull me aside and
said,
look at this fucking clown.
You're not trying to be judgemental.
You just know that he's pulling the wool
over anybody's eyes.
We know who's talking to talk and
walking the walk.
We see it on stage,
we hear about it.
We only twitter or facebook hear about
it.
We get to that club.
The club owner otitis joel.
Joe was here two weeks ago.
He was falling asleep on stage.
You know his shit.
Right?
So it's the same thing.
Yeah.
No,
I think so.
I think,
um,
I think what's one of the things that
stand up is good for is it's,
it's an
exercise that you're doing while you're
living your life and the better stand up
gets.
It's usually a better indication that
you're thinking better.
Like your life's more in order you more
tuned in,
you know,
you're dealing stuff that's hitting
harder because you've got better points,
you know how to edit it better,
and they usually that you can use that.
I think it's like,
remember,
see,
remember that moving mo.
Betta blues',
denzel Washington.
I love that movie.
One of the things I loved about that
movie,
I got inspired to work on my act after
that movie.
I was like,
thinking about how much musicians
practice.
He was just,
oh,
he's practicing.
And these girls,
these hot girls would want to fuck.
And you're like,
no,
not right now.
I got to practice.
I was like,
damn,
the discipline crazy discipline that
that man has to play that trumpet and
practice it over and over again.
And it made me really think like as a
comic,
we don't work like that.
We don't have to rehearse all day,
you know,
we don't really rehearse at all.
But musicians like a really good
musician.
I mean they're always working,
they're always trying and training and
working on their craft and we do it on
stage in front of people.
Probably more than a lot of musicians do
unless they're constantly regularly
touring.
But it's,
we don't,
we don't have that kind of a work ethic
attached to what we do.
Like if you want to play a phenomenal
trumpet,
those guys,
their breath control and the way they
can blow those horns,
man,
they practice all the time.
They put an hours and hours working on
that.
And I was thinking about it.
That's a different kind of craft.
It's a different kind of craft.
The,
the ability to play a musician musical
instrument,
the thing about standup that becomes a
problem sometimes is that it's kind of,
you can kind of pull it off like you
could do it really well or you can kind
of pull it off and to kind of pull it
off.
You don't need a whole lot of effort and
just need a few good subjects and a few
good ways of expressing it,
but to get that where you can kind of
pull it off and turn it into a bit.
That just smashes a bit that you put it
in the.
You can't wait to get to that punchline
because you know it's gonna be a nuclear
bomb.
That's where the real work comes in and
I think for a lot of us,
it's the difference between how much
energy you put towards anything,
whether it's your standup comedy or
painting or whatever the fuck you do.
How much energy put towards your
writing,
how much energy to put towards thinking
about it.
The more you can do,
the better it's going to be,
and that's a fundamental thing that
nobody ever tells you.
People tell you you should write,
but it's not just that you should write,
you should also listen to your shit.
You should also perform,
but the whole key to it all is just
applying different kinds of focus
towards your act and if you look at like
a movie like mo betta blues,
like he's doing,
he's playing that fucking trumpet and
you realize like this guy is like lost
in the act of practicing this beautiful
musical instrument and this is his craft
and he takes pride and being excellent
at his craft.
He could just hang around all day and
still probably blowing awesome tune at
night,
but no,
he fucking practices and I remember
thinking about that going,
damn,
that's probably something that's missing
from the lives of most stand ups and I
should probably try to think about that
more with my own life.
I love.
I love the
writing and I love the performing.
I hate the listening.
Yeah,
that's a hard part.
Listen,
this is very rough for me and I
listened.
I forced myself in before the special.
I forced myself to listen a lot and it
made me to fucking over critical,
you know,
got me to over fucking critical a week
before I tape.
I also went to places that I didn't put
my name on the gazebo just to see how my
job should do in front of regular people
and that fucked with my head a little
bit.
A couple of little mistakes in training
camp,
but that's a training camp before.
Don't worry you.
No,
I agree.
It's not been doing this for 27 years.
I loved doing it.
I get better every fucking year.
My breathing,
I get something better going up on stage
or confidence levels and a talk.
It's 27 fucking years.
You're going to be doing 30 this year.
Next month is going to be 30 fucking
years.
Did you ever see yourself doing this for
30 years?
I still remember walking into the main
room and mitch,
he was in a booth and paul was onstage
slice in that room apart and she called
me over and she goes naturallY
happening,
no income.
He 20 years and at that time I was like,
damn,
I've been doing comedy for 11.
I still did anotHer nine and now I'm at
27.
Crazy and it's like you watch people
like john john,
right?
Who will fuck you up effortlessly
without even breathing heavy.
John jocko.
Yeah,
you'll be in.
You'll get that fucking hell.
You think you got them in the fucking
guillotine.
Next thing you know you're on your back
and looking up with the army and that's
what we're doing right now.
I feel myself when I see a guy with a
coral belt on,
I'm like,
that's the level now that we're at.
I can control a lot of shit.
Joe,
one of your secrets was following me.
It was putting yourself in bad
positions,
which in jujitsu is like getting the
biggest guy in the room and go,
hey,
you busy right now.
Did I tell you on the road with me?
They'd be like,
what the fuck is wrong of me?
And just choked me.
You taking me on the road is like
somebody going,
hey,
come here for a second.
What do you wait $300?
I weigh 1:40,
get on top of me and amount.
I put one hand and we'll start there.
Let's start right there.
Start right fucking there.
Only if you think about it that way.
See,
this is what's important about it and
there's one thing that's important about
traveling with all really funny people.
It only becomes a negative when you
think at it as a negative.
When someone's funny,
you should be laughing and enjoying it
and it
makes your time more enjoyable when you
go on stage.
Yes it does.
I needed to learn that and the way I
learned that,
one of the ways was going on the road
with you.
I knew that you were going to crush and
so I knew that everybody else would like
to take,
you know,
we were both relatively young in our
comedy careers back then.
Right.
So it was like we're talking about,
I've been doing comedy maybe nine years
or eight years.
You were a lot wiser about the game,
like you introduced me to shit,
but I've never even like I read a few
books,
watched a few tapes,
but you had the practical knowledge that
I needed.
Like you were the votech school.
Well,
what I did is I thought about it the
same way I thought about martial arts.
That's one of the reasons why I wanted
to go on the road with your all the
time.
I was like,
you don't get better or aspiring people
that suck.
You get better when you spar with
wizards.
You gotta be real careful when you're
sparring with wizards and so it was
like,
what I would need to do is have someone
who goes on stage in front of me and
just crushes and we had some.
I had some Tough sets going on after
you.
I remember one time in rascals rascals
and a west orange,
right?
Was in west orange or east orange,
west west orange,
New Jersey.
Fucking great club,
but you went up and you got into it with
some people in the audience about
something and you were just on fire just
on fire.
You crushed and I had a real hard time
going on after you and I remember
thinking,
oh,
okay,
this is a very important lesson.
Like this is important.
Like there's something that I'm not
doing right that he is doing right,
like,
what am I?
How come I'm not,
oh,
I'm nervous.
I'm nervous going on after him so I'm
not having fun up there.
So he's having fun and I'm being tense
going,
oh jesus,
it's better not suck,
so I'm putting in my head this better
not suck.
It's the total wrong way to approach.
Like if you approached a fight like
that,
man,
you're going to get smashed.
Most likely you want to approach a fight
thinking about the things you're going
to do,
not the things that you want to like
worry about what's going to happen if
you get hit,
you don't think like that.
You just think about doing your thing
and then adjusting along the way,
and I had the wrong mindset and I needed
to see someone kill a bunch of times in
front of me and then bomb,
go after them to realize something's
wrong here,
the wrong things,
and I'm going onstage tense because
someone was funny.
That's ridiculous.
Like I should be the opposite.
I should be happy that someone was funny
because I love comedy and this is what I
like to do.
I mean,
I like to watch it if I'm not doing it,
so why am I so tense?
It was just a bad way of approaching a
problem and I think this is one of the
things that fucks people up in life.
You approach a problem the same way
every time and you never stop and just
completely look at the whole thing from
the top down.
JusT look at the whole thing.
Go,
what?
What am I trying to do here?
I'm trying to get tighter and funnier
and better.
What do I gotta do I gotta do a lot of
sets.
I got to write and I got to work with
murderers.
That was the key.
It's like working with guys like you and
all of us working together and also
people knew if they came to see us like,
hey,
this isn't just going to be.
Joe goes up and he's the hero of the
show.
Now you're going to get ari who's going
to go on and murder your going to go on
and murder and then I'm going to go up.
I mean,
it's a fucking
rock 'em sock.
'em robots show.
We had.
We went on the road,
dude.
We did cut college clubs or other across
the country.
We did.
I mean who knows how many fucking
cities.
You and I and already toured on fucking
crazy numbers just over and over again,
bonding together,
hundreds of shows together,
figuring out how to fucking get
everything perfect.
Figure out the right amount of weed to
smoke before you go on stage,
the right amount of getting joey diaz
riled up.
You would come in yelling about
something or hair or I want you to see
something.
I'd go into the bathroom and they'd be a
shit.
It looks like a crocodile trying to
crawl out of the toilet bowl.
All that stuff.
That's some rock and roll comedy,
man.
You know,
it helped both of us.
It helped both of us a lot and it also
like set a tone that I think for a lot
of us,
like you should be with funny people
should all.
Everybody should try hard.
Should not think that anybody doing good
is bad for you.
It's great.
it's great for you.
It's great for everybody that
everybody's like doing good together is
better for everybody.
When I go on the road now I go onto the
road and those joe rogan principles,
right?
That's my whole road thing.
The only thing I added to the leg added
to it is my travel fast.
I don't fuck around.
I don't want to see nobody.
I'm.
Yeah,
go right over there.
You know,
there's no radio necessary.
I played just like,
you know,
we,
they'll try because they have
relationships with local radio stations.
They like,
you know,
casey ewi wants to get you in there.
Cool.
I go in because you want to talk to the
people on the way up.
The same people for sure way down.
There's a lot of people that were there
for me when I was in.
Sorry to do this station.
The problem is the waking up in the
morning but just killed.
It just kills her and you've got to get
in there a day earlier because if you
want to do friday morning,
you gotta get in there thursday now.
You can't just show up friday,
3:00
in the afternoon.
I can't do it.
I fly out thursday.
It fucking sucks man.
That's the best you got out of me,
right?
Because was I got the family and I got
people.
We got a lot of shit.
It's not like it used to be mad so.
But the thing that I love about this
time is that even though people are
super sensitive,
like we were talking about,
people are real sensitive about getting
in trouble for stuff.
There's still rock 'em sock 'em robots,
comedy going on.
It's still wild up there.
Like dudes are still doing crazy fucking
jokes.
It's fun.
People taking real chances that doing
real stand up,
you know,
and there's a lot of them that's built
burr.
There's.
You can go down the list.
Ari,
ari's doing real standup.
You know,
there's a bunch of real killers now.
Santino,
he's doing some dangerous stand up.
You know,
I'm writing for my.
That's it.
Like the reason,
the point of that fucking story I told
you,
being on top of that hill at 17 and
being homeless is because I had a lot of
chances to ice myself.
Show has a lot of chaNces to ice myself
that could get not a fucking prison.
And thinking about getting out on bail.
when I got out on bail,
I had a lot of fucking doubts my friend.
Thank you.
Get not a bail and knowing you're going
to look at 48 fucking years and you're a
fucking loser as it is.
Think of all those opportunities.
I used to break into a friend's house to
sleep in this house at night.
I slept in a rocket ship for a month
outside of the park.
You and see those rocket ships and your
kids play on them.
I still remember going up to the third
floor,
the rocketship finishing off my coke and
jerking off on the third floor at five
in the morning outside in the fucking
park with leaves around me and shit.
So it was a lot of times I had that one.
It's amazing.
You have no fucking idea.
I would go up to the third floor with a
bottle of fucking schmear silver vodka,
a bag,
a hooded sweatshirt,
gloves with a missing finger so I could
fucking touch the rock and put them in
my nose and shit.
You know?
No,
that's funny on the way up the stairs
and shit.
But when you're.
When you come down and you're in that
rocket ship,
it's five in the morning.
It's 22 below zero and you're thinking
to yourself,
fucking god took a.
When my mother got did this,
this is all god's fault because it's the
same guy I was raised to believe that
was going to help me,
is doing all this.
Lot of times I wanted to fucking do a
swan dive,
but I didn't.
You know,
it's so fucking weird.
That was in those positions for a long
time.
Joe.
Now I got to look at you and go,
jesus christ,
look at what I turned this.
No,
no.
Tina turner'S son killed himself
yesterday.
It wasn't.
I thought it was like son with her,
you know,
this trend of fucking people isin
themselves.
That scares me.
That concerns me.
Is this something where we're eating?
This is something that we're getting
weakened,
you know,
there was no drugs and bourdain system
so we can't blame fucking prescription
drugs while he was on one medication,
some sort of medication.
Um,
and it was something that was prescribed
for them.
Someone told me that it was malaria
medication.
I don't know,
probably,
I don't know if they've released that,
but I'm sure he had to take some of that
stuff sometimes,
but you know,
you don't know what it was that did him
in.
According to some people,
he really wasn't doing well.
You know,
I don't,
I don't know.
I need to.
I mean,
it's almost unnecessary to get,
for me to get the full story.
I missed the guy.
He's gone.
That's it.
You know what I mean?
I don't need to.
I think when whenever someone does
something like that,
whatever it is,
if there's one thing that people could
point to and say,
hey,
there's a chemical that's responsible
for this,
or there's a gene problems responsible
for this or the like,
how could someone who's loved so much
want to step out?
I mean that must be a terrible moment of
pain to want to do it.
I had ever been on the computer
listening
to music on youtube and you're right and
it just keeps playing songs and you
know,
you don't have no control,
but I think I started with lending skin
skinner,
a simple man kept going to the one
that's going to trip and I went.
I came back and at one point blow up the
outside world and I'm sitting there and
he says that line about going out or
something.
Joe rogan,
my lip started shaking like,
I'm like,
I don't even know this guy and I miss
him.
This guy,
you want me to look you people will tell
you.
I know.
I met her.
I met chris.
I don't know.
I never,
I saw him one time at the comedy store,
60 feet away from me,
chris cornell,
that's it.
And I started crying like how could
somebody like this go in a room and just
iced themselves?
Is this what I'm going to do because I'm
in this fucking entertainment field
because what happens?
And then I think about all these times.
One time I broke into my friend's house
and I broken the window and it was
freezing so I couldn't even sleep in
that room.
I had to sleep in the hallway and there
was a mattress on the wall that had like
piss stains from older kids and I pulled
it down and I slept on it and when I
woke up he got a dog and it was too
cold.
He just let the dog shit downstairs and
there was like 20 pieces of little
rolled up shit that had been like when
the juice goes out of them,
they just roll up.
Once those things that you use it as one
of those accordion accordion,
it was like a piece of shit straight.
It's like an accordion.
What the moisture goes out of it.
It really does take a shit that's this
big and you put it in a box.
come back a week later.
It's like this big,
how do I know that?
Because I didn't to a guy in prison took
a shit in the welfare box.
One time jesus boxes of cheese with the
cheese comes in american cheese.
This dude had long hair and will always
try to play me like he was with the
biker dudes comebacks for him.
But he played he where he lived in a key
working in the kitchen.
He forgot I ran the kitchen and there
was all me and black dudes.
So when dad got one of the welfare
cheese boxes and I took like a 22,
24 inch,
it looks like a lizard.
It was just a long like,
you know.
Then at the end,
like one of those things that like a
snail brown snail mail,
I fit perfectly into this cheese box and
I took a flag,
an american flag from the cheese and I
put it on and I put it in this drawer
and every night and he had the first
bunk on the way out so that everybody
had a walk and all the black guys were
opened that door and go,
god damn,
it smells like shit in this
motherfucker.
And he kept saying,
I know it does.
I don't want to answer it.
I was like,
shit in there and after like a month
when they went draw,
everybody kept saying,
man,
it smells like shit.
Then he went in this drawer,
opened it up,
and they found this box.
He opened it up and I never forget him
knocking.
I'm like going,
I'm going to find out who did this to
me,
what they do to you.
And he goes,
look at this.
And like,
well what is it?
And I knew his shit had shrunken down
from the 24 inches to six inches.
Just shrunk down with all the moisture
goes out.
It just shrunk down like a fucking.
I don't even know why I'm telling you
that story.
That's hilarious story.
That's fucking crazy.
It's a hilarious story.
He's a fun times.
Joey diaz.
I think we're the last of the regular
humans.
I think we got our children's
generation.
Maybe one more after that and I really
do believe it's over.
I think we're going to integrate with
fucking computers.
I think we're real close to it now.
Can even go whole podcast without
looking on our phone.
Oh,
what time is it?
You know,
It's weird.
We're going to integrate with computers.
We're going to all be living in some
weird world.
we got this fucking virtual reality
thing here.
Now.
The htc vibe should try this thing out.
It was freaking the fuck out.
You think you're another place.
There's a zombie games and games where
you're on top of a castle defending the
castle,
shooting arrows down at monsters that
are coming at you.
We're wearing 10 to a weird world right
now.
Joey diaz.
Computers.
Too much information.
Joe rogan part of these thIngs too much
and from what?
Listen,
I'm this thing,
I do not have social media.
Good for You.
You do know that I only have twitter on
it.
Oh,
that's social media.
I don't have facebook.
I don't have nothing on social media.
My hotmail.
Hotmail.
Oh nobody.
Even people when I tell people out
middle,
they go,
what the fuck are you talking about?
So you limit your into your interaction.
That's good.
That's smart.
And limit my interaction.
I'm the road.
The ipad.
No social media.
I'm convinced we're going to flex and a
writing on my ipod.
That's it.
What do you use for writing app?
Whatever came with it.
Writing whatever it section.
So I have jones books,
I have chapters.
This died.
Thoughts.
So I'm working on.
Is it notes?
Is that what you write on?
I don't know what it's because like
they,
it looks like yellow paper.
No,
no,
no notes I have on the phone and I write
on here from time to time,
but nothing too follow you write it on
something that's on your ipad.
Yeah.
So what I do is I'll write on a notebook
in the mornings and then once I take the
baby to whatever,
I go to the coffee shop in and transfer
it if I really like it to the ipad and
I'll work on it from there,
and then I look at the whole thing as a
whole and stuff and the notebook and I
don't know my spelling and I can't
remember what that word was and the
social media part is a big part of all
this that I'm talking about and said
we're just getting closer and closer to
each other in some weird ways is going
to be nothing compared to the next wave,
whatever the next wave is,
what they really do.
Figure out a way to integrate either
virtual reality or what they're calling
augmented reality.
What you'll wear a pair of sunglasses
and you could have google maps sitting
up on it.
He can google things.
You could see images
give you navigation.
It's going to get real weird.
Joe.
I see joe rogan.
I'm still a fan of life.
Me too.
It bothers people and it bothers me when
somebody is not a fan of life,
so I don't want him around me anymore.
Who's not a family life.
A lot of people we forgot.
We forgot.
Yeah.
Too many cameras.
Too many pictures,
too many videos.
Listen,
I was raised in society.
You don't see too many really talked to
me to find pictures of me as a young
kid.
Really thought,
yeah,
there's not a lot of pictures taken back
in society where and I came from a
society will put the camera away.
Right.
Good.
What's that?
For tHe camera?
Yeah.
Why but put the camera.
Well,
we need more of that backstage,
right?
My way.
You know we live.
You know I,
I'm a stern believer.
I don't like text messages because I'm a
prick or a douche bag.
I want to hit joe rogan's voice.
No,
we've taught some people.
I don't want your fucking voice.
I want to hear your voice because I know
what you're thinking.
If I hear you voice it,
can't I care about you?
I care about you too.
So I want to hear your voice.
I told us telling people that I love
that thing that you do,
like you don't want to have My one
friend.
The only time I ever texted you is if
you text me first.
Yeah,
I texted you back,
but I call you.
We talk on the phone.
You have to check in.
You have to have that.
You.
You have to be as human.
These days.
I don't have nothing on my books.
I don't want to do comedy,
but guess what I'll do.
I'll push myself.
I'll be sore and I pushed myself to go
row because that's human contact and
it's.
It's,
it's,
it's the most positive human contact
you'll ever think about your role on the
street with fighting about something
means knuckles and I grabbed you and
pull you into cars.
If I'm fucking,
that's is human,
so I know I'm not going to do this,
but I'm not going to do that.
Then to rent a lIttle bit,
maybe spend some time with the girls.
Maybe I'm gonna.
Take the girls for dinner,
but I also know that I'm gonna.
Make myself have that human contact of
jujitsu.
You,
oh,
you're gay.
Joe,
are you just a closet fag roller with
men.
That's great,
but I had human contact.
I had an emotion.
I shook hands with the guy.
The guy sweat on me and I sweat on a man
which builds a certain type of emotion
between two men and then they'll have to
be a homosexual.
That's a different type of fucking man.
It really is.
It is.
When you stop what you're doing and go
jojo.
Jojo.
Jojo stopped after.
Get the hook and while you're teaching
me something,
I'm sweating my fat fucking potato
chips.
Sweat is landing on joe rogan's neck.
but you going joe,
he grabbed my neck.
Squeeze.
Yeah,
there you go.
Now do that to me.
Next time.
You know what that does to your psyche
as a man that a man that's beating you
is teaching you how to get up.
So joe,
I got in this guillotine,
but stick in co and you're sweating and
you're like,
no,
no.
don't just put your hand in at one time.
Just squeeze real tight.
Good.
Joey,
joey,
you fucking killing me.
Jesus.
Joe,
that's a complete different part of a
man.
I think so too.
I think that that you think is good for
you.
No human contact.
It also alleviates the tension of like
men have tension that they might get
into a physical altercation.
You don't think that way.
If you do jujitsu,
great.
You relaxed walking.
People are scared of vitamin d.
The society scared people have sunlight.
You got to get on with something.
A little bit of depression because
depression people talk about again,
you know,
I many times I had to be depressed.
You know how many times I've had
opportunities to call you up and go,
I'm depressed.
I get depressed for 10 fucking minutes.
Right?
Then I smoked the solutes and expired
fucking chiba chew or I think of
something that you said and I left my
fucking ass off.
You know,
on the way up here I was high as fuck
and they used to be.
This guy that used to fuck with me at a
body shop was a detailer.
Used to fuck with me every day.
Couldn't beat him up.
He's a lot bigger than I would,
so how to use my mind.
So I saw a dead mouse one day.
I took him out of his jacket pocket.
He was driving to work one morning and
he went in his pocket for a cigarette
and he found the mouth and he crashed
his car.
Oh joey,
we're at almost four hours.
All right,
let's get the fuck out of here.
Get the fuck out of there.
I love you.
Thank you very much for having me.
A vegas.
Utah's sold that.
I'm in Kansas city with you.
I'm at the improv.
Why urine?
Oh,
doing the theater Like gentlemen.
And then I'm in nashville in huntsville,
Alabama at the end of the year.
But besides that I'm home.
It was a pleasure seeing you.
Look great.
I love you brother.
We'll take your off for up and we'll
train them.
We'll have jamie.
We'll come in,
we'll do a cycle of dIfferent
cardiovascular machines and then we'll
do a circuit of the cardiovascular
machines and do a circuit of some
kettlebell exercises.
Would do.
Can you do chin ups?
Chin ups at all?
How's your shoulder?
Terrible.
Okay.
Have you ever done clubs?
You've done clubs,
clubs,
clubs.
I do the crane club workout friday.
I'm going to steve,
my man,
joe schilling and shit.
Beautiful.
Get a little tune up from uncle joe.
Bunch of shit on here.
We got madison balls and have a nice
workout.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
I'm down here,
man.
We could do that.
What time do you usually get here?
I think you dropped the girls off and
then you shoot right over.
A lot of times I come here early and
workout,
but sometimes I can't do it until the
afternoon,
but we'll work something out.
We'll do some shit and thank you for the
experience.
Disneyland.
Jesus fucking christ,
bro.
It's fun,
right?
But just the way you told me to do it.
Like I looked at it.
My wife's like,
what are you crazy?
I go,
listen,
the medicines,
there's only one way to do it.
I invite our brother,
addy.
We had a great time with the kids heard.
It was awesome.
It was awesome man.
Thank you brother.
Thank god for some place like disneyland
when you have kids,
when you.
When you didn't have kids,
who gives a fuck about disneyland,
but when you have kids it's like,
oh,
taylor stopped me at the gate because
they found them that a boy.
He did tell me they fucking let and then
they ate half of it and the guy goes,
I didn't see you.
I was naive.
I love you.
Joey did 4th of July.
Everybody for the july by
great.